all right so it's been i don't know how
many weeks since the last major piece of
critical infrastructure was held hostage
by so they say russian hackers and then
the company paid the ransom within a few
hours and it still led to this massive
oil pipeline the largest pipeline being
shut down which resulted in people panic
buying gas and there being gas shortages
across the east coast
and uh now the largest meat processing
company i believe in the world with 23
of all u.s beef production and 20 of
pork production has just shuttered all
of its plants due to
a cyber attack more ransomware i'm
beginning to wonder if this is actually
ransomware if they're specifically
targeting critical infrastructure now
early on this uh this this company or
hacker group we're gonna call it
darkseid said you know it was a mistake
we didn't want to disrupt society so
we'll choose our clients better next
time and now here we go again is it a
different organization well they're
saying it's russia again so at the very
least we're being attacked our critical
infrastructure's being attacked and now
we're hearing the white house is scared
there's going to be a meat shortage
which is funny because there already is
the prices of meat has already
skyrocketed there's already you guys
have seen my instagram where i post
where the guy says i can't sell beef the
price is too high so this is just going
to make things worse
it's a bit chaotic right now and on top
of that you get the mainstream media
saying like everything's a-okay the
economy is doing better than ever and at
the same time joe biden's printing
trillions economists are warning the
dollars on the verge of collapse people
have become millionaires by buying fake
money and people are now interestingly
engaging in what we would refer to as
kind of like an occupy 2.0 a digital
occupy wall street where people are
sticking it to the hedge funds buying up
these stocks they tried short selling
which is well in some ways rescuing
these companies making a lot of people
rich for a silly reason but screwing
over a lot of the wealthy elites so it's
kind of like a class war is happening on
top of an actual war or something i
don't know but we're going to talk all
about it and joining us to help us
understand the financial aspects of it
we've got financial youtuber matt coors
who's hanging out
i really appreciate being here i think
we have an awesome discussion tonight
you wanna just do like a quick you know
short introduction who you are what you
do yeah awesome so for those of you who
don't know me uh name that quartz i'm on
youtube just talk about a lot about
stocks options crypto just kind of
what's going on in the market and
recently the hot topic has obviously
been amc and it's very very similar to
the storyline of what we saw in gamestop
back at the end of january or early
february and even today right now we
were just talking about it of how much
it ran today and then after hours it's
up almost another twenty percent yeah
these are black swan events back to back
like this is statistically more rare
than just lightning striking over and
over again i think i think it's a new
kind of some kind of conflict some kind
of warfare i mean people might just
think it's funny to buy a stock but it's
really up ending the system you know oh
so i will say full disclosure i do have
amc stock i bought i bought a small
amount earlier just because yeah so most
people know i'm friends with cassandra
and she's been tweeting like crazy and
i'm like you know like fast nine is
coming out and everybody knows the ffcu
is way better than the mcu by like
several orders so i'm excited for the
movies and i was like i think movies
make sense to you know to invest in but
we're gonna be talking about amc stock
it's skyrocketing i mean what it was
like three bucks what months ago yeah i
mean at one point like sub five it's
just been on the craziest run and back
in 2020 got that low like at the end of
it so
it's coming far away i mean from monday
until this moment it's probably up close
to 200 percent from monday until now
like a little bit over a week we have we
have art on the wall from this guy
george alex opolis and one of his comics
is this like grandpa being like i don't
have a lot to leave you son you know i
don't have that much money and he goes i
just became a millionaire buying fake
money i'm like there's something wrong
with the economy right now and it's not
just the fact that people become
millionaires off crypto and stocks and
these weird moments but i mean our
infrastructure's under attack joe
biden's printing money like crazy there
was a house that sold wapo reported this
a million dollars over asking price and
it's it's huge news because people are
panicking to get out of the dollar rich
people are like i'll take it i don't
care so we'll we'll get into all this
it's going to be a crazy discussion
about the economy we got ini's hello
everyone ian crosson here i've got a
crystal ball i don't know if it's in
frame a little bit
part of it you're here matt thanks for
coming man it's gonna be awesome what's
your youtube channel by the way just
matt kors very good super cool simple
love it i'm really excited to have this
conversation with matt because as you
guys all know this is not really
something that i'm well in tune with and
he's a great explainer
good conversation
but before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
this big old members only button we have
stripe and paypal as options you can
sign up and click the members area and
there are exclusive segments from the
team gastero podcast and last night matt
brennan was actually here he wasn't on
the main show that was joe kent but matt
brennan was actually here
he gives an update on what's going on
with these audits in arizona and new
hampshire and i can only tell you this
we're not allowed to say what he said on
youtube no joke it's a bannable offense
and there's some pretty interesting
things he said so that's what
timcast.com exists for so that we can
have those conversations outside of
youtube's censorship and he said some
pretty interesting stuff he it's not
going to break it's not shattering the
the news cycle it wasn't the apocalyptic
it was just like hey here's something
that's happening it's really interesting
you know and and i think it's
significant we're like oh wow that's
interesting and face you know youtube is
like we'll ban you if you dare talk
about it so at 1ps.com become a member
but uh if you if you really do want to
help out you can like this video
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends we don't have a
big marketing budget we're not like cnn
they get propped up by youtube which
gives them the equivalent of probably
hundreds of millions of advertising
revenue just for free because they're
authoritative well if we're gonna
compete with that here's what we do you
guys who are watching smash the like
button seriously and then share the show
be at the podcast or the youtube link
take the url post on facebook twitter
wherever you can and uh and tell people
to give it a listen because we're
talking about stuff that is i mean
well we'll probably be a bit partisan as
we usually you know we're not big fans
of the establishment which includes
republicans but uh mostly democrats but
we're gonna be talking a lot about the
financial markets and how it's screwing
everybody over and i think everyone can
get behind that so share this video but
first we got to talk about this big
breaking news check out this story we
got from yahoo finance
all of jbs's u.s beef plants were forced
shut by cyber attack
let's go for the quick quick quick bit
here they say a cyber attack on jbs sa
the largest meat producer globally
forced the shutdown of all its u.s beef
plants wiping out output from facilities
that supply almost a quarter of
america's supplies
of america's beef when they say supplies
all the companies fed beef and regional
beef plants were forced to shutter and
all other jbs meat packing facilities in
the country experienced some level of
disruptions to operations now this means
pork as well
according to an official with the uh the
united food and commercial workers
international union jbs did not
immediately respond to requests for
comment i also want to point out you
know most people don't know this this
you know there's a there's a chicken
shortage
did you hear that so now there's a
double shortage of like just all types
of meat i think there's i mean there's
ridiculous shortages chlorine shortages
computer chips gpus obvious for obvious
reasons there's uh shortages of cars
there's shortages of chicken and what
else is what is this
it's a bunch of weird stuff that's like
you can't get but this this is important
because
there's a shortage of chicken
and the first
the first hint of chicken shortage the
media went oh it's because of popeyes
you know they made the chicken sandwich
and now everybody's buying it so there's
none left you know seriously that's what
they said and i was like that's not true
that no one's buying that much chicken
from popeyes
but they're like but it's the chicken
war kfc's got a chicken sandwich and i'm
like but all they sell is chicken but
popeyes i'm like it's popeye's chicken
that's all they sell and they're like
well burger king burger king's always
had a chicken sandwich no one is going
as fast with restaurants and being like
give me 10 chicken sandwiches so i
thought that whole thing was weird then
i covered this a few weeks ago
when you look at local news what do they
say chicken shortage chicken shortage
chicken shortage restaurants can't get
cooking oil restaurants are charging
more prices higher prices and i'm like
why isn't this at like the national
level why does anybody know about this
how come it's only the small
towns that are saying hey you can't get
chicken so something weird is happening
i wonder if
it's worse than they actually say it is
because
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you know get
conspiratorial anything on this one but
there's a cyber attack on colonial
pipeline which shuts down the biggest
oil pipeline in the country
and just before that happened some
people were saying there's like a
massive leak of oil some people have
said if they paid the ransom to the
hackers within three hours of the hack
why did they shut the pipeline down why
did dhs come out and say there was no
shortage when like 87 percent or 83
percent of gas stations in dc had no gas
they blamed it all on people panic
buying which some people did but i'm
like i don't know man it's is it
possible the media is just lying to us
that is totally possible yeah yeah how
about that you wouldn't say yeah right
so now we're we're we're here the white
house is saying this
the white house is worried there could
be a major meat shortage soon soon huh
no but this is crazy because there's
already a shortage on beef
it's it's it's it's not even it is this
is crazy to me that they're saying this
and i wonder why is this happening after
the shortage already hit so i posted
this thing on instagram
i don't know if you saw it but there's a
barbecue shop not too far away and like
two weeks ago they put up a sign saying
due to the increased price of beef we
can't sell it anymore because the price
per beef doubled and they said it was
because like gas has gotten so high it's
impossible to get beef so i'm like we
went we have a bunch of farms around
here and so when we went out to try and
find farm meat the shops all the farmers
were like yeah we're struggling to get
beef like the the regulators are not
letting us you know harvest meat or
whatever it's being restricted so i'm
like
it's kind of weird man
the word they phrased it a major meat
shortage makes me think maybe we're
about to see something we've never seen
before at least in this generation
with the other shortages you were
talking about is there like reasoning
behind that i think you said the chips
make sense i've been paying attention to
that but i think you said chlorine is it
because like production was stymied in
2020 and like now we're seeing the net
results of that or is there like a
different reasoning per one i kind of
think uh
well what's the best way to describe it
um
the system broke
and the the the
the establishment is desperately trying
to bail water but what they're doing is
making it worse right so like
they shut the economy gets shut down by
all these different governors with with
the coveted lockdowns
that is like a freight train going full
speed just stopping dead in its tracks
what happens well all the carts derail
and fly off the tracks it doesn't just
stop you can't start that train back up
so people don't realize when we're
seeing this this stuff have you seen
these fast food restaurants like
mcdonald's offering a thousand dollar
sign on bonus yeah that's crazy right
nobody wants to do the job people see
that stuff and they're like
oh isn't it crazy that you know
mcdonald's is offering all that money
and then what you hear from a lot of
these like younger leftist types is
maybe if they paid a living wage people
would want the job
what they don't realize is biden is
giving everybody 300 bucks per week
bonus not to work
so people don't want to work but what
they what they aren't seeing is so
they're like so pay more money okay well
you can't just pay more money they're
trying what what what else it is
you can see fast food restaurants you
can see people aren't going to
mcdonald's you like aren't working at
mcdonald's what you can't see is they're
not steel mills either they're you you
can't see the farms where people aren't
picking the crops you can't see the
people who work the beef not there
either so it's not just mcdonald's it's
across the board people aren't taking
jobs anywhere they got a bunch of money
and they don't care so this is crazy
like so it's it's a weird thing that's
happening at the same time we get this
the media telling everybody to eat
cicadas uh don't don't don't eat have
you seen these stories don't eat don't
eat i just don't want to eat one yeah
well you shouldn't they're parasite uh
they could have parasites
they're they're nasty have you heard
them scream oh god no have you ever
not up close what does it sound like
yeah yeah so you know you know how you
go outside you hear the noise in the
skates yeah that's all at the same time
but it's their wings they're not really
screaming when you when you when you
find one and you pick it up it flattens
its wings and you hear you hear go
ahead and it's like really freaky oh
that's the vibration from the wings
fluttering yeah that's why i grabbed
them by the way super super crazy creepy
noise man anyway the media has been
pumping out articles like crazy telling
everybody go eat these bugs
and now we got one from the atlantic
that's kind of honest about they say
unfortunately some cicadas taste like
nature's gushers if you must eat them go
for air fried dude they're gross we made
um
mid cricket bread
yeah and it's it's like different
it was under what did you think i see
yeah underwhelming underwear not great
not not horrible yeah i wouldn't call it
bad i would just say like you need it
for a specific kind of food like i think
it would work with a meatloaf yeah
savory for sure mommy
i wonder we didn't use it like four and
a half cups of the cricket flour we just
had like one cup of cricket flour like
three and a half cups of white wheat
flour but it was definitely noticeable
that it's something going on you gotta
you gotta you gotta get ready for the
better so good for you too it is it's
got like twice the b vitamins and
protein of uh beef
so you got to eat the bugs man that's
the future well going back to supply
issues cicadas only come up like what
once every like 13 years or something
isn't that there are cicadas year-round
but the big surges are
every year yeah there's a case every
year but they're you barely see them
you'll you'll hear a little bit this is
brood x where it's just like insane the
17 year cicadas are nuts
and uh we've been feeding the chickens
chickens love them
uh bucko our cat was just sitting there
like really slowly just mauling once
like taking his time with it
you know and because cats like that when
it's still alive and it's like
struggling
so uh
yeah i don't know i brought this one up
just to be like as an aside we got these
meat shortages coming and they're
telling people like it's time to uh to
eat the bugs
i kind of feel like
a big problem with what's happening
is for one joe biden is doing this
unemployment boost they're doing the
child tax credit so they're giving
people money like crazy nobody wants to
work there are supply side issues
then at the same time we get these cyber
attacks and that's why i kind of feel
like it's all kind of weird you know
i'll give you some historical context
about the idea of conspiracies real
quick and then we'll go to the next
subject but
when uh the gulf of the gulf of tonkin
incident happened that's that that that
was when the u.s claimed to have been
attacked and so we were forced to enter
the vietnam war never happened
i guess historians now say it's it's not
true
that it was it was a false flag or
there's no evidence to claim that we
were attacked in the gulf of tonkin and
it was likely just made up so that we
would enter the war when that happened
people had no idea like imagine you're
like sitting in your room and then all
the stuff is happening in vietnam and
you have no idea and then a week later
you find out or more importantly like
imagine the revolutionary war you're
sitting in your house you just finished
you know farming or whatever and at that
moment they signed a declaration of
independence 400 miles away you have no
idea you find out a month later when a
postal carrier shows up you're like oh
it went independent last month i guess
all right so what's happening right now
which is which i find interesting
is that
the media wouldn't be telling us if
there was a very serious conflict
happening something that was targeting
our critical infrastructure they
wouldn't be telling us if something like
right now there could be a very serious
thing that just happens there could be
another cyber attack a case in point an
insurance company got hit by a cyber
attack by ransomware
before
the uh colonial pipeline yeah we didn't
know about it they never reported it so
this kind of stuff could be happening we
got no idea and what's crazy is the
media will tell you you're a conspiracy
theorist if you if you if you
pontificate on why is it that we have a
meat shortage
why is the people aren't working
and then a meat plant gets hacked
the weird thing to me about it is
why would why would hackers go after
oil and meat production
wouldn't they want to go after i don't
know an insurance company
or banks
the grid
electricity oh yeah that'll be the next
one electric grid
one though so many people are dependent
on it yeah but they just want a quick
ransom right that's what you see it
sounds like you're saying it's an act of
war against civilian population
i was just thinking if you went for the
most damage wouldn't that be your goal
if
if you so so the hacker group came out
and like said like we don't we didn't we
didn't mean to affect society this way
so if you're trying to make money to be
a millionaire you don't want to shut
down an oil pipeline you need the gas
too
uh you want to eat a cheeseburger same
as everybody else you just want to be
rich yeah so why go after
meat and oil
instead of like
a financial institution
unless there's something going on that
we don't know about
which is gonna
get worse
there's the theory that the govern the
the the market was crashing anyway and
that they they people were happy to use
the covid lockdown as an excuse to start
printing massive amounts of money and
just expediate the the crash ultimately
so if that was the case there then we
see like a meat shortage so maybe then
now they're expediating that
by trying to hack it but then that just
leads towards malice i don't know if
it's like a malicious hacker or a
government agent that's doing it to
disrupt like a chinese thing or if it's
just easy targets well let's talk about
let's let's let's now jump into the uh
the financial aspect of all of this
the uh as i mentioned you know joe
biden's printing six trillion dollars
now he's got a new proposal more money
pumped in the system it's going to hire
people to build stuff but the wall
street journal reported that people had
a decent amount of savings people have
people are flush with cash they said
families have cash there's just no
supply there's there's demand no supply
so if people can't buy what they want to
buy and there's nothing that's going to
bring it back
why would they go start working again if
joe biden prints all this money and says
we're going to hire you to go build a
bridge they're going to be like for what
i got a bunch of money and i can't buy
the ps5 anyway
so now we're seeing something
interesting
people with a bunch of money and nothing
to do with it
and this is where we get to this story
from market watch a huge day for meme
stocks sees mudric reportedly dump amc
stock and roaring kitty returns to rally
gamestop die hards what does this mean
yeah okay so uh
roaring kitty and i'm sure a lot of
people might know the the details a lot
of this stuff um but so i'll just i'll
just briefly mention there's meme stocks
there's you know gamestop amc i think
what kodak nokia were those part of the
bush so uh
people started buying this stuff because
memes were popping up telling people to
buy it but there was sound motivation
behind it i guess it started with with
gamestop
so i covered this a little bit we talked
about on the show is the game stop
rebellion people were basically saying
these hedge funds are committing illegal
act are engaging in illegal activities
they're doing naked short selling
they're shorting more more shares that
actually exist which is manipulating and
destroying these companies which is
unfair and so this dude's like i like
the stock and he buys a bunch of it
rallies a bunch of people and i i
wouldn't say directly he's like hey look
what i'm doing so then people were like
we'll buy the stock too and it screwed
over all these hedge funds so a lot of
this ties into crypto but let's just
start from the beginning and then you
know
take us to where where we got to go
what's happening right now amc is up
38.50 i think it's like a share of amc
so it was at one point like a couple
bucks
people are shorting it so what's going
on tell us what's happening yeah well
first of all congratulations i know
there was a lot of people were watching
it today after hours it's just
continuing to go bonkers and really this
entire
group of stocks are just highly shorted
ones and it all started with this
roaring kitty character back in 2019 he
just slowly but surely on reddit posted
he liked it gamestop
and throughout 2020 it really got some
traction just the stock was doing a bit
better but
people liked the size of it like
way back in 2019 he put like fifty
thousand dollars on it or yeah fifty
thousand and confident and then in 2020
the world shut down a lot more internet
consumption people started taking note
of it and then in january it started to
pick up and that's when it went crazy
like he was up millions of dollars it's
just like one guy it was just insane and
like everyone's looking at the money and
he just it was funny because like he was
the guy who started all of this he was
diamond handing it no matter what i
think a lot of people are faced with
that money were like oh how could you
not take it and he just kept he didn't
trip so explain diamond hands we we have
a shirt but you can bring diamond hands
it's more of a reference to oh really
almost poker like if you have a strong
hand you don't fold so diamond being the
strongest thing it's like you're just
not fully no matter what happens
technically fundamentally you are just
not getting out of the position
and that just caught i think it was
really the perfect storm of a couple
psychological events of people in 2020
hurting for money sitting around hearing
this cool story it was perfect it played
into that narrative that resonates with
a lot of people of david and goliath it
was this underdog this one guy calling
himself roaring kitty and well he
actually uh has
uh the other name dfv and people just
liked it they liked that
value yeah they liked where it was going
with it and then when it it exploded in
january for those of you who don't like
haven't been following this story that
closely in late january before we knew
it gamestop was trading sub 50 and at
one point in pre-market was about 500
and market hours was about 400 it was
just it was going so crazy and people
were making a lot a lot of money
so at that point what had happened is
this all happened because there was a
high short interest in the world of
stocks you buy a stock you hope it goes
from x up to y and you profit that
difference you know like if it goes if
you buy a stock at five it goes to ten
sell it you get five bucks profit yep
exactly so in the stock market there is
an option to do the opposite you can
sell it at y hope it goes down from 10
down to three and you profit seven
so with that the only way to pull that
off is how could you sell something you
don't own well you end up borrowing it
from someone and it's basically an iou
you want it to go down you buy it back
and you give it to that person well it
got so out of hand with gamestop at one
point
out of all the shares in existence there
was a and forty percent short interest
against it
so like people were like how is that
possible how could you possibly short
more of the stock than even exists
because like someone was borrowing it
and then selling it to someone else who
was then used using it to like and then
someone borrowed it from him yeah it was
just this never-ending daisy chain of i
own it i loan it to you you short it he
buys it he loans it out it was just
buying loaning shorting buying loaning
shorting and it was just recycling and
it got so huge and actually what we just
explained to the letter of the law right
now not a financial advisor not a lawyer
but that's legal that is a legal
practice right there you can do that
naked short selling that's what i just
described is not naked short selling so
that's normal shorting and that's
allowed and what it is it's just the
amount of people are getting caught
because like when you have that much
money betting against a stock
historically it does go down because
it's just big money they must know
something we must be getting it right
but once in a blue moon there's enough
people that start to pile in against
that trade and to get out of short to
close that position you have to buy back
to the market well say i have a big
short i closed mine i lost a little bit
but because i bought it to close the
position at a small loss it goes up a
little higher well you hit your risk
tolerance you're another short it goes
up a little higher you hit your risk
tolerance and before you know it it gets
so wildly out of hand because all the
shorts are covering they've gotta buy
stock to cover yeah they hit their risk
tolerance and like if you own a stock
your risk is technically capped if it
goes to zero if you're short of stock
your risk is technically infinite
because it could just keep going up and
up and up and that's what happened when
you have so many shorts mathematically
the ceiling just goes higher and higher
for every short and so people saw this
phenomena and they found other highly
shorted stocks so gamestop led and like
hey i kind of missed that train but all
of a sudden you have bb no cost and one
that really really caught people's
attention and honestly why i'm here
right now is because of amc so people
noticed it and in early february all
these highly shorted socks kind of took
a breather but at that point the amc
community specifically it exploded on
reddit twitter and youtube why
i think something about the point of it
was a psychology play of with gamestop
if it was trading at 200 bucks you could
buy one share and then if amc is trading
at 10 you could buy 20. so you just felt
like you could buy more like there was
more of a psychological reward
especially with a potential massive
squeeze incoming it's like well make
more money people just wanted more
shares
what's kind of funny about that is that
it doesn't matter how many you have it
matters the percentage gained yeah you
know so if you if if you like when it
comes to bitcoin everyone's like oh i
can't spend 40 grand in a bitcoin it's
like no it's a percentage gain it's like
you put in 100 bucks and it goes up 10
you made 10 bucks it doesn't doesn't
matter however when you realize that
people think that way then it actually
kind of is better to have stocks that
are cheaper
because instead of thinking about
percentage the person buying is going to
be like wow it's only a dollar i can buy
10. so they actually drive the price up
faster because the stock is worth less
per sh or it's worth less per share yeah
and with that as the community grew this
is like they were talking about naked
shorted with the first game sub thing
but now that it's been a couple months
since early february there's been so
much dd and research going on and this
is where we entered naked shorts which
isn't a legal practice so in the example
of i own shares i loan it out to you you
borrow it you pay the fee you short and
that daisy chains so what naked shorting
is is actually when you take the short
position
and you never ever borrowed it it just
did not exist so you just added more
supply out of nowhere it exists
digitally but you're in increasing
supply demand stays the same so it's
driving the stock down you just increase
supply like so with that and then it
gets more out of hand because you bought
these fake shorted chairs like people
refer to them as synthetic shares
because they never should have been
shorted
you bought them off of him you think you
have legitimate chairs so then you loan
them out to someone who actually want a
short and you get this tree root system
of all these actions that should have
never happened because of the initial
naked short so the system is basically
it's got a bunch of hollow points
and then what when when the when when it
comes due what happens
so that's the interesting thing is so
the way we're using a broker you like
you sign up to weeble or whatever it is
you have a broker well hedge funds have
prime brokers and just a fancy name for
whoever facilitates their trades so
really the prime broker is the person
who is supposed to locate the shares for
them to short but uh to the best of my
understanding they have like two days to
locate them sometimes they don't and
they could even kick that can down the
road and before you know it in high
volatility stocks throw so many trades
so much and you just don't know how out
of hand it gets so really they get a
slap on the wrist they're supposed to
buy the shares that should have never
existed off the market and they did it
but one of the main things i kind of
stress to my audience is yeah okay you
bought those shares off but there's no
way to get back any of the damage that
was done from like the result of how
long they were on the market so so hold
up let's think about a second uh it
sounds to me like uh what what's what's
what's amc amc uh currently short
interest what percentage of amc is 18
and that's the ones that are legitimate
legal shorts inherently you can no
there's no way to track illegitimate
shorts because they were never
documented and hence why they're
illegitimate was it wasn't gamestop like
over 100 it was at 140 at its peak
where's it at now
percent twenty okay so it's way way down
in terms of yeah but but if it's over a
hundred percent then it's basically like
a guarantee they're gonna have to buy
your shares off you at some point no
matter what the price is
not a guarantee because with that much
money betting against it usually they're
right and they actually drive it down
that was the argument is that there were
so many hedge funds piling against amc
gme and these others like there was a
good chance of them forcing it to go
bankrupt but with
a whole bunch of bored
internet people yeah that's a really
difficult thing to go up against it's a
hive of bored people with stimulus
checks you know and i think that's one
of the things really going against the
hedge funds right now of from early
february till now the community
specifically in amc is getting bigger
and bigger and bigger uh the ceo adam
aaron was talking about there's 3.2
million
retail investors individual investors
and that was actually a little bit ago
so now it's just the word is spreading
even this me talking here more people
are finding out about it and it's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger so
at first it was the story line of david
and goliath the little retail traders
but now there's so many little davids
that you almost have like a whole nother
goliath versus that original gloss this
is interesting there's there's some
questions about the the
the security and the value of like a
stock for instance because they can
always dilute you know when we look at
dogecoin for instance the price goes up
simply because it is a scarce commodity
to a certain degree its price reflects
its scarcity and the demand for it so
bitcoin is becoming increasingly more
scarce just by nature of what bitcoin is
people want to use it because it's a
safe decentralized store of value so the
more people want to use it the price
just keeps going up so people are
holding it are happy and people want to
get in because it's going up and it's
like a system where everyone's just like
we got to buy more which just drives the
price higher and higher
with stocks
they could dilute and that could
negatively impact you all of a sudden
there's more shares they get sold and
now it devalues a lot of you know a lot
of the shares but at the same time
it's not incredibly common that they'll
just keep printing shares right it's not
they can't just do that can they
well there is a process where you like
ask for shareholder approval to
authorize new shares then they're
authorized and the board and the
leadership team when they deem it
necessary then they can do it so like
there is a certain i guess process that
they're going to go through but even
talking about that that happened to amc
today
so well the price still went way up
exactly so it's not a definitive thing
because sometimes you're diluting or
you're
you're doing an at the market offering
to raise money and then it's the
perception of the public of did they do
it for a legitimate good reason so
yesterday they sold about 8.5 million
shares for around 27 they raised 230
million the reasoning for it and the ceo
tweeted out was to acquire more movie
theaters expand their market share and
then today well this is a whole nother
weird i guess turn of events it gapped
up it was strong midday the hedge fund
that bought it
actually sold it and they not only sold
it they did it all at once and they did
it during the market hour which is a
really really sneaky tactic and the
reason it's sneaky is because midday
especially from 12 to 1 everyone's on
lunch it's the lowest volume part of the
day wow so whatever you do has the
biggest impact
so the whole point of that
psychologically is you see the jump
people get scared they get an alert and
it trus it causes like actual
capitulation people are like what's
happening yeah it hit stop loss orders
it caused capitulation and then people
get scared they're like hang on i don't
know what's going on it
people the
one of the quickest things to drive a
market up or down is greed in fear and
that's what you do like
so when stock goes up you have fomo
buying they just see it ripping and
everyone's like i want to buy you hop in
on it the opposite true is you see a big
red bar you get scared and because you
get scared you sell someone else's sell
like
the stock market is so emotionally
driven and sometimes that could be used
to a benefit and other times it's not
but it was just so strange that they
bought it
at 27 like that and then they sold it
today
and
not only was it a weird timing and they
did it all at once you could see the
volume traded in like a particular three
minute time frame but beyond that they
went out of their way to make a public
statement that it's overvalued so within
one day they loved it at 27 and then
they tried to drop it at 32 33 they're
scamming the market yeah that's what it
sounds like and it's weird because like
you'll have some correspondence talking
about all these retail traders
manipulating the market how is that not
right when you know people are paying
attention to it and you go out of your
way to make a public statement where
it's just listened to and that's what
why this is getting they're just
throwing gasoline onto the fire with
this type of thing when you act that way
because people who are on the fence of
like maybe there isn't manipulation
maybe we're overstating it then they
hear story lines like this and you're
like what are you possibly doing like
it's so so bad and then
there's a couple of things more things
that play into it but then the reader
media reports on it and it's always like
retail they shouldn't be doing this blah
blah blah like it just gets so out of
hand and it's just feeding the fire
bigger and bigger this is what i was
saying earlier on with the other segment
about you know meat shortages and stuff
was uh that it's like the system is is
collapsing and they're trying to stop
they're trying to bail water but they're
making it worse i look at this way they
they they issue this unemployment bonus
you know everybody's now getting extra
300 bucks a lot of people have money
from you know their jobs not everybody
was working but people have money from
unemployment and nothing to buy so
here's something you could buy you can
download an app and just buy something
it's like what else are you gonna do
with it right so all of a sudden now
you've got this massive short interest
on stocks like gamestop or amc or
whatever else and 3.2 million retail
investors who can't go anywhere can't do
anything and are bored and are like yeah
i'll join in i'll buy something
so
you've got this this this lock down they
shut everything down it damages the
economy then at the same time people
have nothing to do so they switch to
this which causes hype this it's it's
like everybody pointing a laser pointer
at the same spot at the same time with
like millions of people it's gonna
actually you know start burning and now
the hedge funds are freaking out so it's
like you know biden and the democrats
think we're going to do this
unemployment bonus it's going to help
people but instead it just causes more
destabilization in a sense if if people
are able to or i i i don't want to frame
like a bad thing i mean these hedge
funds shouldn't be able shouldn't be
able to do what they do anyway you know
we had uh are you familiar with max
keiser no so max keiser is a big
financial guy he's a big bitcoin guy and
he was on the show talking about how
this hedge fund just get they get free
money from the government anyway the
government just prints stuff gives out
the loans from the fed and then they can
just do whatever they want with it and
it manipulates the whole system and it
basically strips the value from
working-class people all of a sudden
whether intentional or not working-class
people said i want to play the game too
and now they're you know firing their
lasers all in the same direction and
it's causing serious problems for the
ultra elites
and the financial system itself which
has been stripping value from
working-class people it's just
it's exactly that it's that like the
pompous attitude of an elitist of like i
know what's best i'm doing it right let
me gut the economy to make millions or
billions myself
and like work in class hey you'll be
fine like just i'm right i know what's
going on with money and they get so so
angry about it of like they're using all
these antiquated models of like
fundamental analysis of game stops
overvalued amc we have to short it you
don't know what you're talking about
well at the end of the day
value is a perceived concept if i want
to buy amc at 50 and if enough people
want to buy it at 50 it's going to trade
at 50. that's all it is there's no rules
it's
it's unsettling to some people but it is
legitimately a house of cards and we
we're the ones who give it value enough
people give it value and that's what
it's going to trade at so
is 18 short interest enough
to actually have like a massive short
like gamestop yeah so that that's an
awesome question uh obviously people
compared to gamestop and like hang on
that's a lot lower um in terms of
magnitude it is considerable uh tesla's
considered to be a highly shorted stock
it's not at six percent and then you
have a normal stock so tesla's at like
five something five point eight percent
sure that's considered high yeah that
that's a shorted stock and then a normal
stock like apple's at point eight
percent shorting is a very abnormal
tactic in the stock market most funds
most everything is a long only you're
buying and you're hoping it goes up um
shorting it is definitely bucking the
trend so i get it 18 20 uh what gamestop
is that now is just like i think it's
20.6 the last time i checked
um
like
yeah it's still just high the magnitude
is there because
as of now in existence there's about 500
million shares of amc that's how many
there are so that means there's about
135 million roughly that are on loan
that we know about that could be
legitimate shorts so what happens is it
goes up
those hundred thirty ish million shares
have to be covered for at a certain
point they're going to hit their wrist
the price has to keep going up yeah and
beyond that
their back
is like they're fighting time because
every single day they pay a borrow fee
but if you own amc you just sit there so
so pay no extra fee you're just like
let's see how this goes so again i
mentioned this earlier on full
disclosure i do have some amc i also i
bought nokia because i like i you know i
generally genuinely thought those they
were good ideas like cell technology i'm
a big fan i used to do a ton with mobile
tech i used to have my own app and uh
then with amc it's like the only thing i
ever really used to do like when we go i
don't go out we go to the movies like on
the weekends we'd like go see a movie
and so i'm like that's something i care
about i also at one point had stock in
blizzard okay because i'm like what do i
do and what do i care about video games
technology so i bought some amc but it
sounds like
this short interest is high
and it
if everybody just decides to buy some
amc stock
then
the short sellers have no choice but to
hire massive high prices yeah so what
happens if they can't afford it
well that's to the point where they get
margin called and like you have all
these new sec rules of like collateral
requirements it can get super hairy but
what's even on top of that not only is
it high
over the pa it's going up
the short interest is getting higher
they're taking more bets out of it it's
not like it's staying constant yeah so
there's new players and stuff but at the
end it's literally throwing gasoline
onto this fire it's an interesting thing
so so uh you know i've talked to people
about this it's an interesting gamble
right let's say a stock string at five
bucks
and it's it's got a lot of short
interest because they're like it's a
trash company it's not going to work the
market's changed and then you get
someone on the internet says hey
everybody buy this now goes up to 10
bucks well the people who already
thought it was overvalued five are now
like dude it's way overvalued at ten do
it short it now because you're gonna
make twice the money you would have made
before
then more people on the internet drive
the price up to 50 bucks well certainly
then those people are going to be like
what it's at 50 bucks these people are
insane it's going to collapse short it
now
there every time it goes up and they
think it's overvalued it's basically
two forces
the internet stock stonk meme people are
betting that they can have diamond hands
longer than the short sellers can hold
out so like you mentioned if they got to
pay a fee and you and and the people
holding stock don't then
it's it's a lot it's lopsided in favor
of those who just bought the stock and
are sitting on it oh yeah it sounds like
it's not even a gamble i mean a lot of
people have likened like they're saying
millennials are playing the stock market
like like a casino and i'm like i don't
know the way you describe it maybe
you're wrong maybe i should make it
maybe i should take advice from you but
if you're right it sounds like you're
saying it's a really really good bet
against really dumb people yeah and
i mean there's two things that go into
that a lot of the people who've been
involved with it it's more of the
mindset of
i had nothing before it
what's the issue with going back to zero
right many people like they're like i
have nothing to lose so it's like if you
call our bluff we don't care we're gonna
call your multi-billion dollar bluff
from
i mean this was when the stock's at 30
and i believe this sucks at 38 at 30
from monday till now they're the shorts
are down 1.5 billion dollars
and that's just from monday like it's
been going up before that i mean and we
saw the massive uh we saw what happened
with gamestop when the stock people are
still thinking they're going to win this
game it well i still have dogecoin you
know it drops by like 50 percent on my
hand whatever
yeah i bought more actually i bought
more today i mean and that's just the
whole mindset of diamond handling like
cool they see red when i'm streaming and
there's uh any notable drop cool buy
discount
people it doesn't phase them now it's
maybe it started out as a joke of
diamond hand but now it's truly the
descriptor of people most people's
mindset on this they're like we don't
care i saw a meme it said gamestop is
the new gold and uh amc is the new
silver because people are making the
joke where it's like as long as it's a
scarce resource that could be a store of
value
and it can't be copied
store your money in a stock i guess
because it doesn't matter if the company
is doing well or not if people just
believe in the stock yeah so it's it's
like you know we had a uh
we we we routinely have people here who
who say i'm not fans of bitcoin for some
reason right and they always go like
where's bitcoin's value come from and i
was like confidence
a lot of people like bitcoin it is
scarce
it uh it's a deflationary currency or i
shouldn't say currency it's a division
deflationary store of value and uh
people feel confident that if they buy
it
they will retain or gain money so long
as that confidence exists above a
certain threshold it's going to keep
going up and if you when you see goldman
sachs and you know morgan stanley and
whatever when they're all just basically
like yes we're bullish on bitcoin i'm
like okay well all right then so so
what's why wouldn't i you think crypto
is good
you look at gamestop yeah they could
they could issue shares i suppose or
whatever same same principle though it
is a scarce
object that can't be copied and people
feel confident that buying it will store
their value or make them more in this
instance a lot of greed the funny thing
is
it seems like
the power of the internet and the meme
factories
is that the meme magic in this is is is
real
and the media's attempts at manipulating
isn't working right so they they i think
what recently like uh cnbc called
gamestop and amc penny stocks or
something like that and game stops at
like 250 and amc was trading at like 20
like broke to 20
everyone's freaking out and they're
saying it's penny stocks they're they're
trying to meme it down yeah but there's
too many people online who are like
i'm just gonna buy it anyway yeah here's
the way here's how i feel about it i
bought doge and i'm just like i honestly
don't care
i bought it because i want it and that's
it yeah i'm not i some guy made a
million dollar like become a millionaire
off doge like good for him he's still
holding like yeah yeah a lot of people
are buying these stocks just to have
them because i think about it this way
you get a check from the government that
you don't need and they give you like
600 or whatever a stimulus and you're
thinking like i don't know what i'm
gonna do with it you can't buy a
playstation they're all out it's like
okay well you know i got a computer i
can play computer games uh you know
whatever i'll just buy some game stuff i
guess and they forget about it and then
they're just holding it and not caring
because they didn't need it in the first
place i
it blows my mind uh
just this was over the weekend and now
the stock's even higher this post market
is a new all-time high so as of last
week i was getting dms from people
between options and stocks they would
send me a screenshot of their weeble not
even like the highest tier of trading
accounts
up 2.3 million
i was like oh like what are you doing
i'm throwing it back in like it's just
what are you gonna do with the money
they're so pot committed to this play
and i love it and like the hedge funds
or even now there's some retail who
think is going to go down and they're
betting against it i think they've
played it wrong in two very notable ways
and the first way they did it was
actively speaking out against it they're
going on certain news outlets and
they're just fanning the fire one of the
best things they could
it's as weird as it sounds they don't
get the internet
as soon as you tell someone not to do
something it's the first thing you want
to do so there's one analyst out there
and about a month ago he came out with a
price target of us on amc as in it's
going bankrupt it's not worth it
and he keeps doubling down and every
time he does it the he now has not only
blocked everyone in the community which
had to take hours of his life he made
his twitter private because like
everyone was just arguing with him i
mean that was the joke like i was even
tweeting he was like wait is 30 bigger
than a cent like i'm not the best at
math i'm dumb money i just don't get it
but like my it's in the green like it's
the game to us and like they just don't
get it and which
that has not only thrown gasoline on the
fire which i keep saying
but now some of these other hedge funds
they're joining in on our side blackrock
the world's biggest hedge fund is long
vanguard is long they're lying on amazon
they're switching it and they're buying
huge amounts
they're taking out a competitor like
they're the agile ones that are clearly
seeing the landscape and they're like
well we're gonna take this one out
melvin capital was the one that was like
notoriously against gamestop in january
february
he was 50
in the first quarter
but like what's weird and this is like
what irks i guess the average person
if you blew up that bad
they just got bailed out uh cohen's .72
and citadel they're like ah we'll buy
you out we're fine
and like when you really look into it
like on the top level it's fun and then
when you look into it i truly get the
the frustrations if i sold something on
the street that legitimately did not
exist i get in serious trouble i do it
two times i could go to jail yeah you
the more you do
but someone like citadel does it and
it's a fine you look at the fine and you
look at the profit from that trade you
make a hundred bucks you're five and ten
why would you ever stop that practice
ever stop that practice and that's just
one of it like you look it up citadel
like from 2006 until now
there's like 20 times 50 or some absurd
amount of times that they were caught
which doesn't tell you how many times
the finra and sec did not catch them
right doing stuff and it doesn't matter
they have so much power citadel
security's world's largest market maker
we are not getting away with it's just
it's insane here here's here's a big a
big big problem i see
what do you do with the money when you
get it
let's say you're somebody who uh uh you
get stimulus check you bought a bunch of
uh you know stock of some sort it
skyrockets you're a millionaire
what do you do with all that money i
guess you could buy a house the problem
is the housing market's insane people
are buying property side and seen we
mentioned earlier in the show there's a
wapo story about a house that sold for a
million dollars over asking just because
people are like i don't care how to buy
the house so sure you make a quick
million bucks off doge or gamestop or
amc what do you buy with it what can you
buy with it we've been waiting for over
two months to get a new computer for the
studio had to order it when you did an
upgrade and they're like sorry we're all
out of chips like what's gonna wait i
guess so i think what's happening is
it's good news for the little guy in a
certain sense it may be bad news for
everybody in the long run
you've got people who are making tons of
money
and there's a reason why they're putting
it right back in
what else they gonna do with it
i think for them because they started
pretty close to zero many many people
they're just like well let's see how big
i can get it for like they just
the joke is when lambo but they're
basically describing like when do i get
life-changing money
and i mean just anecdotally i don't have
the stats on it but like the thing i
hear is i finally paid off my student
debt i finally paid off my mortgage i
finally am not begging verizon to keep
my internet on and like and then other
ones it's like very sad like i mean when
i started this you project yourself on
it i'm 26 i thought it was fun i was in
on the bet
and then i s through this platform that
i've been so fortunate to have
like you get real stories like some
people were reaching out to me of just
super super sad things of like i was
financially stuck in abusive
relationship and i can finally leave
that and like that just resonates like i
started this for the lows and the jokes
but like seeing what it's become and
like positively impact it and i get what
you're saying about like certain
material things but i think um
just how on like a deeply human level
how upset people have been like with how
their life has been going they view
they're clinging on to hope and i think
that cling onto hope
is the exact reason why these hedge
funds they're not going to end up
winning it because i think they're
undervaluing people's ambitions to hold
on that it starts as the joke but when
you like really unpack the psychology of
it
i just don't see how they end up winning
this particular one i think uh
a lot of this is
evidence to to state that the u.s dollar
is going to collapse to to some degree
meaning
it'll exist i'm not saying it will cease
to exist but uh
if you've got people who are getting
millions of dollars and then just
putting it right back in
if you've got hedge funds now joining in
and people don't want to work
what's the value of a dollar if you
can't buy something with it so if
somebody's got millions of dollars in
stock they don't need a job
if people are getting paid by the
government unemployment checks bonuses
they don't need to work if you can't
even buy the playstation you want then
what am i looking forward to it's
working anyway my bills are covered so
what happens then is the ultra wealthy
the hedge funds who are like we've got a
billion dollars what do we do with it
nobody wants to work
we can offer people more and more and
more money they still won't take the
jobs
the money has no value if people don't
want it that's what that's the value of
the currencies the confidence behind it
but anything really so it seems like
right now a lot of people have more
faith in amc's stock
not even necessarily as a company just
like the meme stocks than they do the
actual us dollars to do something with
oh yeah and i think that's why
what we saw playing out with dogecoin
why it happened it's like i'd rather
take that bet and whether people are
actively paying attention to it or not
you alluded to it before
the
inflation is incredible like the can we
are kicking down the road is way beyond
a can we are rolling a barrel of oil and
there's like a flame right behind it
it's just the the on policy of unlimited
quantitative easing i get it at a high
level of like let's help out with
unemployment let's just see if we can
assist with it but
the degree the magnitude to which it's
like surpass 2008 and 2009
it's just unlimited currency of course
it's going to devalue it and then like
i'm sure you guys are better to comment
on like then what it changes in
competition to the yen and that stuff
like there are serious political global
ramifications of the actions and i'm by
no means an economic expert but like i'm
at least smart enough to recognize it's
not good
yeah i think uh
i'm not gonna tell anybody what they
should or shouldn't do i don't give
financial advice on the show but i'm
buying crypto
oh yeah i'm buying crypto man i was
reading uh what was i reading today well
for one we we saw recently goldman sachs
announced
they're like you know oh crypto's a new
you know key asset or whatever an asset
to uh uh i wrote a class an asset class
so they're like telling people like this
is something you want to buy
and bitcoin is decentralized it's uh
it's possible but you know extremely
difficult to to manipulate i'm you know
there's there's things you can do like
with what elon musk did but i look at
what the rich people are doing and i'm
like they're preparing for something you
know there there was there's a uh
mountain bunkers in like new zealand do
you guys ever hear about this
rich people have like landing strips and
mountainsides
like d-day bunkers almost yeah so like
the apocalypse happens like an appliance
like why not man if you're worth you
think bezos doesn't have a fallout vault
why wouldn't he definitely does like a
seed vault you have that arctic seed
vault they have small bird
no no yeah yeah i think it is yes in
svalbard uh and i don't think i mean
maybe i'm saying straight up like if i
was jeff bezos i would literally make
like a a vault-tec vault i'd be like
just you know i don't want to do an
experiments like they do in the game she
won't have a regular vault so build it
why wouldn't they but they do they do
have things like this they sell like
missile silos that have been converted
into homes you can like you go down like
16 or 20 stories whatever so anyway rich
people have prepared for a lot of really
crazy things but now you look at what's
going on with cryptocurrency
yeah the ultra wealthy are buying into
it big and they're manipulating it big
right so elon musk pulled a really shady
move he announces hey we're going to be
doing bitcoin bitcoin for tesla i think
that was this year right yeah when he
says we're going to do bitcoin for tesla
then he gets a bunch of bitcoin and then
announces we're not going to do it
anymore
then the value drops but what happened
the people who were selling the crypto
were poor people
they were essentially the retail
investors people who had a couple
hundred bucks here and there who
panicked when they saw it collapsing and
like oh no elon musk doesn't want to use
it anymore oh no square says they're not
going to use it so they all sell guess
who who buys it up the rich people the
rich people buy it all up and then after
that dip goldman sachs comes out and
they're like oh by the way we're going
to recommend all of our you know wealthy
clients buy more into this
so i'm like i look at what they're doing
i wouldn't necessarily uh uh
do everything they've done you know
shorting gamestop seemed to have been a
very bad idea at amc
but it all i also wonder if what they're
doing with crypto manipulation is to
cover their losses like a lot of these
hedge funds are like
if we go belly up it's going to be 2008
all over again what can we do and it's
like well let's steal the money from
poor people through cryptocurrency and
use it to cover our losses
it's one of those things that like on my
end of it it's hard to like tie things
exactly together unless you're the one
executing the trade but we really
commonly see the opposite moves as if
they're trying to cover margin
requirements liquidity calls in other
markets and that stuff there's been
and it's an easier asset class to move
money to wash money through like you do
see weird things and i'm like maybe at
that point i'm putting on my tinfoil hat
but like
it's i don't know it just seems very
very realistic how can they you know
i've got two two views on this
how could a regular person think that
they're going to be able to beat the
hedge funds who have got friends in
government covering their asses at the
same time i wonder how can the hedge
funds think they're going to go up
against 3.2 million regular people who
can just flood the zone with cash and
shut them out yeah it's hard to know
which way it's going to go
i mean you could always have i mean one
thing we haven't touched on is at the
start of february the brokerages just
stopped the buying and everyone's like
you can right robin shut up
not just almost all of them right robin
hood i guess became the symbol of it
just because of their name they're like
it doesn't seem like you're robin hood
that's pretty weird robin poor yeah but
um they were
robbing from us but they stopped it and
everyone's like whoa whoa whoa like
whatever we've been pitched of this
concept of the free market really that
seems super not free market hey man like
what's going on and
we're not like the way the legal system
moves it's so slow and like right now
there are certain federal and state-wide
cases against robin hood
but you hope it doesn't happen again but
we're about to find out most likely and
we'll see but
the
amount of distrust in the system at
large whether it's the political system
the economic system i feel like it's
growing and like i don't know like at my
age maybe i just haven't seen enough
maybe it's been worse at other times but
the times that i've been actively paying
attention to it it does seem like it's
up-taking of just like the underlying
anger and distrust for our systems how
much of this is just greed
just people like i'm gonna turn my
paycheck i'm gonna double my paycheck
right now you know what i mean like you
go you work you get a couple hundred
bucks or
i mean a lot of people aren't working
but let's say you did work and you got
paid a thousand bucks you're like
whatever i'll put in an amc for the week
pull it out back at 2000 right
i mean
very possible but i could also argue
it's greed the other way of why do they
keep shorting it they think they're so
right and they're trying to make money
about driving a company into the ground
it's just
i mean i think everyone's in it for
self-benefit it's just like you're gonna
argue your point stronger you look at
crypto's a really good example of the
great i think because we get super chats
all the time and it's like you know tim
you've really got to look into this
particular cryptocurrency and it's
called like you know flobblecoin or
something it's like i've never heard of
this
it's worth like point zero zero zero
zero one of a cent and then and it's
like i personally have 14 billion of
these coins so like everybody's got to
get it it's the new thing and i'm like
is it the new thing or is it just the
one you bought
and you want everyone to buy in so you
can cash out yeah i mean i i think i
even experienced a little bit of that
after the doge run up like everything
seemed to be like they even pitches that
they're like oh it's just another meme
one like they were trying to hop into it
and it i always took the argument that
it's very difficult to recreate a
perfect storm
but man if if gme was one it seems like
the community at large is about to pull
it off with amc again they to some
degree pulled it off with doge and we
don't even know if that storyline is
really over like the same thing it went
up might be taking a breather sell out a
new price and then rip again like
you just don't know but it seems like
all the changes and maybe it's because
of technology it happens so much more
rapidly and uh at just like
the ferocity of it it's just such a
greater magnitude of like just the the
swings up and down just across the board
it's it's it is it's nuts like i'm
watching the like my stocks
and i'm like if i was perfectly trading
like here's the peak cell like here's
the dip buy you'd be making like
millions per day oh yeah just like it's
an exponential increase the more money
you make the more you do and eventually
you get so big you're actually swaying
the market yourself with your buying and
you're selling like the act of buying
the dip makes it spike up and then you
when other people get fomo and buy in
you sell
yeah that it's just you know watching
cryptocurrency prices where it's like 42
33 37 i'm like man people are becoming
billionaires off this yeah the ones who
who are pulling off those trades
perfectly
i i can't i can't see man how an economy
like this works
i i don't understand it it seems like
it's we're not completely off the rails
but it feels like the train is kind of
shaking of it it's starting to get there
it's like really picking up but
i wonder that it's like one of those
things like maybe should i just started
the economy for like five decades of my
life and i'm like oh this happens every
so often or is it a legitimate shift in
the direction that we're actually going
like is it truly unsafe i think i think
there's a shift i think someone's going
to change check us out so we got the
story from
nbc 10 philadelphia in a convenience
store chain first pennsylvania's sheets
i'm saying that very carefully for
youtube to start accepting crypto
we're very excited to be working with
flexa to roll out support for
cryptocurrencies and other types of
digital assets at our stores linda smith
payments manager for sheets set gonna be
very careful with that we're probably
getting demonetized anyway they're gonna
be like you can't say those words so
anyway they announced that they're gonna
be taking uh what is it uh bitcoin
dogecoin
uh uh ethereum litecoin and other crypto
con uh currencies this is a major chain
i mean you've you've had cheats before
right yeah i love sheets you do that was
like my high school it's like wawa
versus sheets college stop stop at place
after like rehearsal it's pretty good
yeah and they got good it was it was
groundbreaking when you could go in you
have a machine and you could pick like i
want a sausage sandwich with onions and
this and then it's made to order first
gas station i've ever seen that at least
more of a selection
i'm a penn state alumni and the current
ceo she's from the area family and
everything so she talked to like some of
the business entrepreneurship classes uh
who do you think their biggest
competitor is sheets yeah
i gotta get creative here so it's not a
it's not a gas station it's the region
so i have no idea i don't know it's
mcdonald's wow what and like we all
think gas but you knew it right away
that it's not gas all their margins are
in food they completely view it to be a
competitive service to mcdonald's and
that's who they're always focusing on
yes it's a good idea it's like if i got
to stop for gas and i'm hungry it's like
oh that one's got a gas pump the other
one doesn't
i guess there's some places on the road
when you're like driving a road trip
you'll see a mcdonald's with gas pumps
but it'll be like am pm gas pumps with
mcdonald's attached to or something yeah
exactly so this is this is big i look at
what's going on with the stocks and i
wonder if it's all still part of the
plan
you know a bunch of people get these
these stimmy checks they throw them in
stocks and then everyone rallies and
everyone's cheering for it and then i
wonder if the big move is to get
cryptocurrency new technology new
opportunity certainly a lot of people
became rich off dogecoin and certainly a
lot of people lost a lot of money on
dogecoin because
it's a game of hot potato i guess if you
didn't sell your dogecoin you didn't
lose anything but some people panicked
and sold and they ended up losing
everything
so i wonder if there's going to be a big
shift and
you know with these with more and more
corporations adopting crypto uh what is
it i think kfc announced they were doing
dogecoin as well
yeah because it's good marketing yeah
and doge might actually be a good crypto
cash
it is a low cost easy to transact coin
it takes a little energy
it doesn't matter uh if it's
inflationary because you're doing quick
transactions with it you don't store
your value in it you store your value in
bitcoin
so it's actually might actually be
pretty good ian's got this look on his
face like such trash dude such
it's such
filamental trash it's like you can make
as much of it as you want and
it has 10 000 per day i think if that's
hopefully they're going to keep making
that much but there's gonna be like what
is it a trillion 30 trillion of them or
48 but think about think about this you
have your money stored your your value
stored in bitcoin and you're like i'm
gonna go to the store today so you pull
up your phone you swipe and say transfer
bitcoin to doge and then you scan your
thing boop and you transfer the dose
that's the future of economics
you have some doge for quick cash and
most of the value stored in bitcoin and
like i think a company should be able to
say if you pay us with those we'll give
you 10 percent off if you pass with
ethereum we'll give you seven percent
off if you pass so then it's up to you
as a consumer to pick the currency that
they want you to use and they probably
are holding a bunch of that currency so
it increases the value of the currency
when you buy it
and then i mean this healthy market uh
it's not the first time we've heard a
big business gonna you know adopting
crypto but i do think it's big because
it's a gas station and there's incentive
now for people to have more you know
what's really fascinating is i used to
do videos on bitcoin and they would just
tank nobody cared yeah you know so a few
years ago i was uh 2018 i'm like man
these bitcoin prices are are crazy and
it would get like 40 percent of my
average view count it's like really low
but if it was an important story i'd
covered it anyway i'd say well you know
i got to talk about this now it's like
we had uh big bitcoin stories and i'm
like definitely going to talk about this
and some of my most viewed videos like
the interest is absolutely off the
charts for regular people looking into
crypto i i would love
for us to be off fiat
and in crypto
100
i'm interested how we're going to
replicate cash because i like cash coin
like will it just be doge cash yes it'll
have like a little rfid chip on the bill
now you have your phone but then it's if
the power goes out you're in trouble
that's the i want to find the uh
the software
well if there's a solar flare i know
obviously i'm going i'm going out on the
line here
hold on theoretically you could like
enter your passphrase
right into any terminal right and access
your doge account
i don't want to put a microchip under my
skin no you don't have to like it's it's
that 10 word phrase right imagine if you
walked up to a kiosk you never needed a
card again you just went you know dog
car
elephant banana ship
and then boop there's something about
having the in your hand and it's like
this is the thing that you want
it's not in my mind it's not in some
database yeah like i can hand it to you
and you can hand me the thing maybe
that's going to be considered old school
because like you can rob it and like you
can't rob an idea necessarily i think i
think we're seeing a great reset brother
oh that's for sure yeah so are you from
the great reset
oh i thought you meant more of like a
higher meta level just like we're
hitting some sort what do you mean
specifically so there's a there's the
world economic forum the davos group
they've proposed something called the
great reset which they just refer to as
a reset of global capitalism so you look
at what's going on with the chaos in the
stock market the chaos and the crypto
markets the chaos in the dollar the mass
printing of money the quantitative
easing
the economic shutdown now the meat
shortages the gas shortages
and
what's happening is that
i think the dollar is going to
you know crap out
and i think
if you can't buy a burger
the barbecue shop down the street put up
a sign saying we don't sell brisket it's
too it's too expensive so it's not worth
it for us i'm like you can't get brisket
at a barbecue shop what are you doing
you know so they do have it now but it
flickered and out now we're here there's
gonna be more meat shortages chicken
shortages
if you can't get it what good is your
money right
gas shortages can't go driving there's
no gas i'm not gonna go wait in line
when those huge lines right out of those
gas stations because the colonial
pipeline hack how many people probably
said you know what i think i'll go for a
walk today huh you know what's really
crazy
you know what's becoming extremely
popular right now
rollerblading
no because bars were shut down
restaurants were shut down and the
repeated sentiment across the board from
people is i had nothing to do and i was
bored so i went in my closet and grabbed
my old rollerblades no joke so now it's
becoming really popular rollerblades in
the us are like sold out across the
board wow oh yeah this is crazy
roller skating too so like women seem to
be roller skating for the most part and
men are rollerblading but this is a
profound change in human desire
all of a sudden there's like videos like
40
you know 40 and 45 year old dudes being
like i'm gonna go rollerblade
because they've got something to do
finally but you don't need money for
that then you get some guy who's a
dogecoin millionaire and what does he do
he's like i don't got anything to do
with it so he buys a lambo i guess and
then puts the money back in doge and
just sits on it it's interesting to see
what people revert to so in 2008 2009
most stocks took like
did horribly but uh tobacco alcohol
actually continued to rise and this in
this last run in 2020
home depot and lowe's killed it like we
have not everyone's doing diy projects
at home they're like i'm i'll do this
it's that garage project yeah it's just
something to do and their online sales
they destroyed it and then what happened
lumber and steel cross costs are through
the roof and now people can't get it
lumber's insanely i'm not uh too
familiar with steel oh actually no yes x
is a stock that it's the u.s steel or
whatever uh
down or up up up um and didn't lumber
just hit a new high it's been ripping i
don't know if it's a new all-time high
so that's relating to home costs going
on so look at look at what's happening
what did the climate change people say
you got to stop eating red meat i've
heard this since i was a little kid all
my vegetarian vegan friends like it's
really bad for the environment
what does greta tunberg say how dare you
we must get our fossil fuels tomorrow
not 2013 not 2025 tomorrow
what gets hacked oil
meat wow what skyrockets and costs so
people can't buy it lumber steel yep so
what do people do they go outside and go
for walks and they go roller skating
they're doing things that don't cost
them money meanwhile other people who
are like buying fake money are
millionaires
like the whole system is out of whack
yeah it's just the it's a great reset
it's the it's
it's people's there's there's we are
experiencing a whether it's intentional
not a reset of global capitalism
people are finding more value in going
to the park going to going for walks
building things and diy projects instead
of owning stuff and eating food and
stuff in their faces have they commented
on like what it looks like after that
like the i guess tendencies or something
like where does it go from the if it is
right where does it go by 2030 you will
own nothing and you will be happy yeah
that's they made a video it went viral
they deleted it because it generated a
ton of controversy
people apparently like owning things
but uh davos group says you will not own
anything and i think that's what i think
we're on track but not owning anything
it seems like there's like a 10 point
thing of do you remember any of the
other things of what they said they gave
like a bullet list of the things they
were expecting to be different
if this was like i don't think the
american government would crash its own
economy but because this davos
great you know economic forum thing is
like a global i don't know swedish or
something oh no swiss swiss i think
davos that i i imagine they're just
like a parasite controlling the federal
reserve making it
allowing it to print print print print
print good for business for them anyway
it seems like
interesting was it 30 30 visions
of a better future what is it
the great reset cutting violent crime in
half uh i can't remember what the
article was i think they deleted it
that's why you will sleep in a pod yeah
it was like like what the future will be
like after the great reset there there's
there's a bunch of stuff like we've got
this one from the world economic forum
saying uh the 10-year plan i'm not going
to read through it but they're like
respect nature and a bunch of other
stuff i don't know climate crisis
to address the climate crisis defend
human rights embrace circularity protect
the amazon and be humankind and
regeneration what is circularity
it sounds so legit
i i will tell you this right now i
genuinely believe
that they are correct by 2030 people
will own nothing and they'll be happy i
think so
maybe
so what does life look like then people
living in vans eating eating bugs
that they're leasing
you know happiness is fairly relative
there are a lot of people who live in
countries where they live in vans and
eat bugs and they love life
there are a lot of people in america who
don't like being forced to have their
resources dripped away and are unhappy
with that
so uh i can understand it but i don't i
don't think it matters i think the
system is is in chaos
like you you can't have what's going on
with the stock market be it fun funny
good or whatever you can't have it it
makes no sense for someone to have to go
and be a sewer tech
wading through five feet of sewage and
then some other dude is like
buying meme stocks and becoming a
millionaire that economy makes no sense
economy like a real market's going to be
like a guy says hey i'll clean the sewer
in exchange for goods and services you
pay for it but now you've got people who
aren't doing much of anything other than
membing and becoming ultra wealthy
eventually the guy in the sewer is going
to be like i'm not going to do this
anymore i'm going to do what he's doing
i'm going to go buy a bunch of stock
and or dosh coin and that's what we're
seeing now we're seeing people who
aren't working these jobs so there's a
shortage of a ton of weird things that
we mentioned chlorine
and there's a shortage of raw materials
to make things which means there's going
to be way more shortages coming soon
i was trying to buy some computers for
the studio like so we tried buying this
one computer two two months ago now
can't get it
they're like sorry you know the parts
aren't available
the latest update is we're hoping within
the next week it will finally be here
nice we'll see but we also need general
workstations so i go online i go to this
you know famous store and i'm like i'd
like to see what you have in stock
nothing wow they had like they had a few
gaming laps i'm sorry gaming desktops i
bought them and they're like not good
they're shortages of everything
and so what happens is
people see this story where it says
you're gonna own nothing and you'll be
happy
a lot of people get mad they're like
what are you going to do take away your
stuff now what they're going to do is
they're going to choke the supply
you can't buy the meat you can't buy the
gas you can't buy the computers they
don't exist nobody wants to work so it
doesn't exist if the ps5 doesn't exist
for a long enough time people eventually
say i'm done i'm done sitting here
trying to buy it how many months had
been since ps5 came out like seven or
eight yeah and i know people who are
like i go on every day trying to get i
can't get it i give up i don't want it
anymore
so what do they do they go in their
closet they find
skateboard rollerblades a basketball and
they go into something else bike yeah
something that's going to keep them
occupied and
this makes me think of like the lead up
to the great depression of the 20s 1920s
and 20s they people there's this like um
we call it like uh mania about buying
stock because all these people were
making massive and then buying it on
margin yeah and they started buying it
on margin
it like leaked to the public that you
could get rich in the stock market so
everyone all these people started
getting involved they started
put buying stock on collateral which is
margin like you you take a loan out
based on something you own and then you
buy the stock with it hoping the stock
goes up if the stock goes down they do
what's called a margin call you
obviously know this but just if anyone's
listing doesn't know and then you got it
to sell the stock at the current value
which is at a loss and then you've got
to recover the cost of the of the loan
and when when it burst and fell
so many people lost everything because
they were in on margin so so maybe we're
looking at a great depression i think we
are and then do we get out of it the
same way just another war
get us out of it do you know about the
uh the the strass how generational
theory no what's that so there's
something called the fourth turning
there's there's four seasons right
and uh i'll make i'll simplify it 80
years ago what was what was happening in
the world
where does that bring us to the 40s yeah
the war we just got out of world war ii
yeah what happened 80 years before world
war ii
was that the 1860s another war what
happened eighty years before the civil
war revolutionary that's right every 80
years we're just in some major war so
that's so there's they're 20 year cycles
and uh so there's there's four turnings
per cycle and we are in the fourth
turning so
independent of that thought without you
knowing about it you said is there going
to be how are we going to get out of
another war
yeah dude maybe
like if you saw it without even without
us even bringing up strass our
generational theory
maybe
maybe people are thinking there's going
to be a war so there's something else
here
so i'm i'm really glad that was your uh
i'm i shouldn't say i'm glad right
but i find it fascinating that your
immediate reaction was how we got into a
war because there's also something we
bring about called the thucydides trap
which is a reference to when a rising
economic power is about to supplant the
dominant power war breaks out and china
is set to surpass the us by guess what
year
2028 which is the final year of the
fourth turning that's kind of nuts
it's gonna get crazy but what's nuts
about
now especially is just the advancement
in technology i think einstein has a
quote about that he's like i don't know
what world war iii will be fought with
but world war iv will be sticks and
stones
he was wrong
why is that you know when people predict
the future they base the future off of
their current level of technology which
is unfortunately incorrect
and rarely do people predict the future
properly you know who got it we've got
who did a really really good job of
putting in the future
star trek the next generation
calling the computer's name and asking a
question now the question they asked
were kind of ridiculous like you know
calculate this okay well you know our
little friendly amazon device can't do
all that stuff but you still say its
name and how to do stuff and tablets the
card would walk around the tablet and it
was touch screen they didn't have touch
screens like that back then so that was
actually a really interesting view that
worked but there's this famous
photograph of firefighters like from the
late 1800s 1900s of firefighters with
mechanical wings
and they're flying and spraying
buildings it's like it's not going to
happen we're not you know we're not we
don't we don't do that so with einstein
he's he's looking at atomic technology
he's looking at all the stuff and he
thinks wow
whatever you know if we have world war
three with this level of of weaponry
anything after it's going to be six and
sons it'll wipe out the planet what he
didn't understand was the expansion of
communications technology and how it's
going to affect people
so now we're in fourth and fifth
generational warfare which is
information war and propaganda
controlling financial markets is a huge
aspect of fourth and fifth generational
warfare
if you're if your enemy can't buy the
supplies they need to feed their people
you win
if you shut down their gas pipelines and
they can't fuel their vehicles you win
if you shut down their meat plants and
they can't feed their people you win
so now we're seeing a lot more of is
internet manipulation
uh uh election interference like you
know russia did try to interfere in the
election
not as crazy as most of the democrats
think but they did as did china as did a
bunch of other countries they're trying
to manipulate things and that's more of
what it's going to be it's going to be
an info war yeah
i don't i don't know if we'll actually
i don't know i think about this this
this fourth turning thing and maybe
we're about to shatter a mold that's
been like we've been in this repetition
state but because we have the knowledge
and we can see the mistakes in the past
that you know governments have have used
the these military-like like companies
to to profit and make we could make
industry with gra like graphene i'm
obsessed with graphene for instance i
know that's expected peak graphene by
2020. he's got a bottle of ground i
bought you the grill i don't know if
you're familiar with this materials
purecraft
pure carbon tim got me this it's
powdered form graphene but it's like a
mono atomic layer of pure carbon and the
use is let's see let's just scale it
let's just we'll slow down it's an
industry yeah to get away from graphene
is very specifically the the the the
general idea is new technology could
change things in a way we don't in a way
that we wouldn't need war for exactly
like war doesn't have to be the way that
we profit out of a depression it could
be technologically through like
materials but that's what
not materials it's through information
manipulation we don't need to drop bombs
when we can just mind control through
social media or or massive you know
media campaigns
it's still war it's still conflict it's
still a battle for control wow it's just
very different so maybe that's a good
thing maybe now it's arguments on the
internet and some are some are in bad
faith some are out of context and
manipulative but it's better than people
blowing each other up i guess oh for
sure
although if an ai tries to put us on a
bunch of pods to harvest our heat
is that better than
than war what if you're in the matrix
bro we probably are simulation theory
i mean we're we're probably going to go
towards something like that would you
get in the pod
the matrix pod you know
um
you've seen the matrix yeah would you
would you rather be you know like
morpheus like people should be free or
would you either be like cypher and be
like tastes like steak
you know
i mean that's a good question maybe
there's
i think people would go for it because
you just feel like you're always going
for some sense of truth like you feel
like you almost want the answer but i
guess that can also be scary because
you're used to what you know it's like
maybe i don't want to take that type of
a pivot but that's tough man it is i
wonder how like in in the matrix you
live a normal life you get steak at a
restaurant you work a job life's not
perfect but it's good
you leave the pod now you're like eyes
hurt because you've never used them
you've got a bunch of holes all over
your body and you live in a gigantic
underground steel chamber eating you
know white goo
but you're free
so would you rather die on your feet or
live on your knees but on your knees
they feed you steak and on your feet you
eat sludge
see that's what the sludge is made of
you know what you know here's the thing
though
i would i to be fair
if you actually have watched the matrix
you're better off leaving the matrix you
know why they can always plug you back
into the the fake matrix where they
could play video games and like download
kung fu
so like the worst case scenario is
you're free from the machines you live a
real life and then like you plug
yourself into your own private matrix
and you know you're a night warrior
shooting fireballs or whatever and
fighting dragons
i thought some of the people though
who the simulation theory on general i
know i'm like pivoting a little bit here
but
math like i get that's the argument of
like you design technology so robust
that you could pull that off and like
are we in that
but if you have this infinite line of
technology that did it and then within
the simulation you did it again blah
blah blah
what is the
statistical chance
that we're at the end one that hasn't
figured it out yet
so like you're saying like we're in
a simulation of a simulation of a
simulation of a simulation if that was
the theory
and like we just had this chain of a
billion long what is this
statistical chance we're the last one
that hasn't figured it out yet that's
possible you know one i actually think
it would be more pretty directly because
there's no proof they say if we would
eventually get there at the path we're
headed then it already happened but that
doesn't make sense because
what if something
stopped it from happening first of all
that you're not taking into account just
assuming that we will eventually get
there doesn't mean that we're already
there
i don't think we've done it yet i think
this is the building process right now
so you you think we're in we're in
reality prime yeah
i'm not so sure
geez good what is real have you smoked
dmt
that's
there's a there's their youtube videos
called like tales from the trip they're
crazy
crazy
i tweeted i tweeted one do you know
about dmt yeah
so there was one guy who basically said
that
he he was he was doing dmt
and then he met a purple woman who like
knew him and and cared about him and
he's like wow and then later he brought
his friend over and his friend took dmt
and he didn't and his friend told him
that there was a purple woman there who
said they're friends of yours
and he was like whoa i never told anyone
about that so there's a lot of stories
where this happens i don't know how much
i believe it i want to see the
scientific research but there's a but
there are stories about you know
research that was done
where people independent of each other
took dmt and then saw the same thing
or describe the same things
it's really weird maybe it's just uh the
drug that affects you in a certain way
and humans are affected in a certain way
that's similar experiences i don't know
it's similar maybe
we're in a simulation you know the body
flushes dmt when you're in near-death
experience and we if you watch like
near-death experiences it's very similar
to dmt trips like they they travel
towards the light they feel they feel
lighter they feel they see the people
they feel and then at the end they get
sucked back in they feel that and i
think that's gravity like pushing them
back into earth so maybe we're actually
there is something out there
i you know just to wrap it into what
we're talking about if this is coming up
on another great depression are the
people that are getting massively
wealthy now somehow like
matrix warriors are they like are they
they're using trainers bro someone's got
to call them on and you get these
hackers out of here because this game is
not fun are they more dangerous to the
matrix so the matrix is trying to bribe
them to stay in it no no it's like
people are hacking and so now you got a
bunch of running around with crazy money
the people who aren't are like dude it's
not fair
i don't want to play this game anymore
some 19 year old dude because dogecoin's
millionaire and i'm working at a factory
not okay
so that's why i say in all seriousness
the economy can't function that way
like because eventually someone's going
to be like
i quit my job at a factory and i'm going
to trade dogecoin
you know
i'm you you could you could day trade
cryptos and and make a lot of money
doing it it's not regulated it's creepy
so a lot of people probably would just
choose to do that has it been like this
the whole time the economy and i just
wasn't involved with it no i think
communication technology made it uh
rapid yes you mentioned like the great
depression and people were buying stock
but you had to like physically buy the
stock you'd like be there ticker tape
yeah the broker like this yeah they're
waving things like robin hood yeah it's
very very different now like the
technology
i don't know what i was reading or
watching but sometimes i wonder if we've
gotten so advanced that
our technology advancement has not also
developed with our brain advancement
like it's exponential in technology but
with us like even certain things
um i think sometimes with psychology of
like social media if they love you or
hate you we're not used to those numbers
like our unit size like we can we're
very good at picturing 20 30 40 but when
you say a number like a million we can't
picture that and it's just how we have
developed and evolved like that's how we
got to this point our brains are very
good at small compact unit types of
things and now social media has you're
interconnected with borderline seven
billion people you ever you ever
actually see a million dollars in cash
no so it people imagine like the
briefcase opens up and it's filled to
the brim and they're like it's a million
dollars and there's a funny skit where
like the mob guy comes in you got the
briefcase and he opens it there's a tiny
stack in the middle he's like what's
that it's like the million dollars and
it's like awesome or something like that
like people don't realize that uh was a
thousand hundred dollar bills would not
be a massive stack of cash a million
dollars is not that big yeah people
don't get it because they assume it must
be infinite it must be huge because a
million is beyond our understanding yeah
our brains are very bad at picturing
large numbers very very bad i think
you're so right that
our brains haven't developed alongside
with technology because i remember 2003
2004 five i think the i first iphone
came out and i was like wow we we did it
we solved it now we have access to all
the information so that means we'll be
able to answer all the problems
and i just thought that's it we did it
2008 is going to be great we figured it
out but then i realized the nefarious
nature of
i remember
my my old candy bar phone what internet
was like on an old nokia you know and
then i remember when the iphone first
came out and it was like whoa it's like
you could like zoom in and out now it's
just normal
so so what's really funny there's a
comic where or a joke someone says
they said if if you could go back in
time and tell someone from the past
something that would shock them would
you say and the guy said
i hold in my hand a device that contains
a summation of human knowledge i use it
to argue with strangers and look at
pictures of cats
it's like
with all of that power that's what we
did with it man humans really are not
that
profound yeah they're not we we like to
view ourselves very highly like we're so
smart we've ended up invented all of
these things and it's like
dude
it's it's sad to me not everybody does
it some people take the technology and
they do great things with it but i think
too many people
argue with strangers and look at
pictures of cats
does it make it fun that there's a bunch
of people like that or is that like a
flaw of our of our genome it's almost
like uh
npcs man
non-player characters
there are people who are like
they get access to the summation of
human knowledge and they use it to level
up increase their stats they're like
strength plus one agility plus one
they're looking up like proper lifting
techniques and then you have a lot of
people who are like on twitter and just
screaming doing nothing and it's like
anger plus one i guess
depression plus ten yeah
some people do literally nothing
they they wake up
they go work a menial job they don't
think about it they use the internet for
nothing substantive no no passion no
dreams not everybody i'm not saying even
most people i'm saying there are a lot
of people that are like this they're
like just npcs just you know milling
about i've had days like that sometimes
i'll go through this like someone's not
necessarily an npc or not but you can go
into npc mode and just train it in
that's for sure i think i think people
some people are definitely npcs just
just
that's their base nature and they you
need to pull them
you can you can give them sentience i
know you can well i'm not saying they
aren't sentient i'm just saying like
i'm not saying they're literally
non-player characters in simulation
although you can certainly talk about
the philosophical ramifications of
symbolism but i'm just saying that
there's some people that have no passion
no ambition and they consume and they
sit around that's it and they're content
to do so most people hmm is it most
people i uh i just watched a documentary
on an author um
jordan peterson love that guy yeah yeah
that was
like many people who spoke to him that
was it like i just i wasn't doing
anything like they they had no direction
or anything and it was just i guess my
sentiment of it was basically a guy like
hey take on some responsibility maybe
you're gonna be a little bit better off
like i haven't really been into that um
but that was like the main reaction with
so many people like that so when you
were saying pulling them out of like
that mpc mode it's like
do something like take it and it's weird
the fact that right now we live in a
time where you can like we say we're
bored blows my mind right right
like we have connections to everything
that like even 50 100 years ago like
those people could have actually been
bored they baked all day and then they
just sat and you just you were done for
the day like that was good enough to do
100 couple years ago here in the u.s
people would wake up at the crack of
dawn go farm go to bed at you know after
after you know late night and then wake
up at the crack of dawn just work all
day go to sleep work all day go to sleep
and then the postal rider would come
periodically with with news they would
have to go to town periodically but
dude people don't realize you got to
look at history
how far apart everything was the
american revolution took 20 years
people think it was like an overnight
thing like
the phone call comes in we're declaring
independence and then the king is like
i'll send my troops and they send them
right over and they're there within a
few days no it took months for the word
to get back to england and to come back
to the states so people for the most
part their lives 99 was farming
or whatever job they were doing in the
town or whatever but mostly not
political now our lives 99 political and
one percent whatever else we do whatev
whatever else it is we're doing why do
you think it is it got so political
the speed of communication oh
yeah look at like there could be a
police brutality incident in the united
states and then people in like
madagascar are protesting and i'm kind
of like why you know like why why is it
that people in london were having
protests for black lives matter
when like something happened in the us
i'm like the british cops are very
different from the cops here what are
you protesting and they just say
whatever you know marxist
ideology i guess
i like that people are getting political
at least desire to be
political so maybe that's a
an evolution or it's pros and cons man
a lot of these people who normally just
didn't care to be involved who get
involved now don't understand what
they're fighting for and fight for
dangerous things
so uh for instance all the people
marching around doing the red salute
it's like commonplace now to see people
doing the communist salute
it's literally what communist chinese
party members do when they are are
joining the party and swearing in now
you've got people in the united states
marching around in the street by the
thousands all doing it
and they say oh but
it doesn't mean that i'm like i don't
care what you think it means you're
doing it
so this is what happened when people who
don't know what they're doing get
involved in politics
is it
even like that though that example is it
another troll thing of just like for
whatever reason like some i guess more
like dark sense of humor do you think
it's like a lack of education of like
what it truly meant
yeah lack of education like imagine if
you saw people like regular people like
a bunch of millennial
you know
urban people marching around doing the
nazi salute
right now they're doing the red salute
the communist salute it's the fist you
know
and they're saying oh but you know it
means something else i guess i'm like
bro if a bunch of nazis went around
doing the nazis thing and meant
something else i'd be like shut up dude
yeah and you'd agree like so you can't
march around doing the red salute what
the communist party if china literally
uses when they're swearing in and then
be like
oh but it means something else oh okay
sure
they they don't they don't so you look
at that photo of all the people doing
the nazi suit and the one guy you know
frumping
yeah man like
most people are just blindly following
along with the authoritarian ideology
that's sweeping across the the west
that's a good point they could be doing
a different salute like a little bit
more creative or a little different than
the chinese communist party salute well
i mean it's not even the chinese
communist party salutes the communist
salutes the red salutes because it goes
back to like you know early early 1900s
europe during the conflict between the
communists and the fascists
you know so they're doing it and they
can say whatever they want about it i'm
like i don't care dude you're doing the
red salute that's creepy like these p
like if you if you blindly march along
with authoritarians who have
historically murdered people and then
you're like i didn't know or it doesn't
matter i'm like okay that's a problem
that's that's what happens when people
don't know what they're doing get
involved in politics they throw
themselves behind
really really dangerous and bad people
seem like it 2000 it wasn't that
political in 2006 i think it's more than
just the speed of communication like it
does feel like i don't want to beat a
dead horse but like the
the global economic forum
is is intentionally dividing the people
in the united states why is everybody
posting ducks in the chat is that oh
that yeah that's it that's just a brand
thing um
like i was just poking fun at how like
seriously wall street people take
themselves so i always wear like a crazy
duck shirt i love it no reason it's just
like a duck gang thing all right all
right we'll we'll we'll uh take super
chats if you have not already it is uh
imperative that you press the like
button to help the show out uh smash
that like if you really want to help the
show and share the show if you're
listening on itunes spotify or whatever
give us a good review and i also will
announce will of the people now
available on spotify and itunes you can
tell your friend a little robot device
to play will of the people by tim cast
and boom it'll play so that's that's a
cool thing that happened and uh don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
let's uh let's read what y'all have to
say smash the like button all right
funeral man 04 says first time super
chat amc has absolutely left me
speechless just like michael knowles new
book jk i admire all of you take care
yes uh michael knows his new book
speechless
all right
tony bolt says jbs is a customer of the
company i work for we make meat-forming
machines last year we had a full-blown
cyber attack that crippled us for weeks
today we stopped another attempt in its
tracks whoa
everyone's spamming ducks now by the way
like so many times since i said that the
whole chat is just oh my gosh
it's uh it's gone off the rails a couple
times when i try to interview people if
they're alive i'm like hey like can i
interview and then the entire group is
just ducks and like what is possibly
going on dude we got another big
shortage uh-oh jack o'neill says i work
for frito-lay and the shortage of
supplies to make chips is getting
ridiculous get back to work y'all lazy
sobs
no frito-lays oh what am i gonna eat
what will we do i don't need frito-lays
who eats fritos i guess uh i guess we
have those barbecue chips sometimes oh
yeah those are good
that's a treat
all right see hennessy says tim are you
going to need a event caterer
event cater coordinator or coordinator
in general for the friday nights i was a
private chef up until the corona um
probably not
we'll probably need a master of
ceremonies of some sort but we may
already have that individual here
uh it's not gonna be like
we're not gonna put out charcuterie or
anything for people they're gonna like
stand outside the parking lot as someone
plays music and everyone like you know
mingles and gets to hang out with people
we're doing friday night events coming
up okay just like anyone's invited or
like a ticket thing like tickets yeah
and it's gonna be difficult because
tickets are limited and there's no
parking so that's the other thing like
taking uber i guess right a bike i don't
know we're in the middle of nowhere
there's nowhere to park so
we might be able to figure something out
but not for 30 people so everyone can
carpool in a bus maybe
well maybe and your first one's this
friday no no no we can't there's like
business stuff we take care of before
we're allowed to do it so
like we were trying to do it earlier in
the year and we got we got you know
stopped by business stuff
regulations rules
uh death's api says duckduck8 check your
po box matt
there you go
alabama toolbox says inflation is a
national security risk the u.s has
military bases in countries around the
world the us navy controls the world's
oceans how is the us able to do this the
strength of the u.s dollar
and
well also the force behind it stop using
the dollar and we'll you know pair drop
into your country you know
all right
let's see what do we got here
blankfield says do you have a yearly
subscription option yet we don't i don't
know uh when we will but i do know we're
like two weeks out from
the website overhaul which should shock
and scare everybody no it's going to be
excellent we're going to be adding a
newsroom so there's going to be actual
articles aggregation we're going to be
uh bringing out some investigative
reporters it's going to be fantastic we
got some mini doc plans i want to i have
a plan to send a joe biden voter to all
of the places that joe biden screwed up
so like i'm talking to my friend who
voted for biden i'm like i will buy you
a first class ticket to mcallen texas to
go and film the kid sleeping in the dirt
and he's like i'm down i'm like cool
let's do it like yeah voted for biden
now you can go talk to people about
what's happening and like if he agrees
with it or whatever i don't know but i
think that's that's honorable that he'll
be like yeah i'll go check it out for
sure you know stand up for what you what
you voted for so that'll be really
interesting like you know biden voter
meets biden biden policy this is
somebody who's not like a die-hard
political tribal anything it's just
regular person who was like i gotta go
vote for biden now they're gonna go
explore and meet people and talk about
what those policies have brought free
vacation i am obviously of the opinion
that they've been bad but maybe you know
send a crew out to go do their thing
they'll come back and beg it's not all
bad
we'll see for sure i'm not i'm i'm i'm
actually fairly confident it is bad but
hey we'll let them do their thing
379 gromer says
the chicken plant was shut down in
russellville alabama for the past two
days i'm waiting to load there now
why
why this is what i was talking about
they say like oh it's a cyber attack
that shut down the chicken
the the meat plant but there already was
a shortage so now people are saying oh
yeah this plant was already shut down
for two days why there was no hack there
was there
what's going on
some weird it's like a hearty boy's
novel
[Laughter]
follow you ian figure it out
it's weird like across the board there's
just like a lot of things that are more
vital the stock market the shortages
like it
it's one of those things that like it's
all these puzzle pizzas
pieces of puzzles that we'll see we'll
see how the puzzle fits together and
right now though like we're all a little
bit confused but
it's like sudoku but instead of like one
by nine it's like one by one hundred
thousand yeah there's like no way to map
out this massive grid yeah it could be
the kovid shutdown
is now they just the media has been
totally silent about it but it's been
devastating the the supply lines did the
media tell everybody on d-day that it
happened right when it was happening i
think so oh dude like literally when
they were storming the beaches they were
like listen i'm america we have started
the beaches of normandy i don't know or
was it like a day later or two days
later they were look it up i'm curious
because i remember we had an office of
censorship
i have a shirt modeled off of the motto
it says silence accelerates victory and
they also said loose lips sink ships so
if there was a major conflict going on
why would the media be telling us
they've never done it before why would
they start now
hey by the way guys is a war breaking
out and uh just keep working actually
you know what i think i think that
because democrats shut everything down
and the media is now the pr wing of the
democrat party i think they have every
incentive not to talk about like big
problems coming our way because of the
shutdown that's just what i think
if that
on the other side of that though if they
were doing it wouldn't we see something
weird on the background of just everyone
like oh like all these tech people are
hot being hired by the government like
wouldn't there be a certain trail like
there's a lot of hiring into some sort
of defensive military force if that was
going on yeah i don't know you'd see
just i don't know i'm picturing just a
bunch of like engineers always being
hired right out of college like no work
for us like we need cyber security
i don't know maybe they are doing that
yeah maybe it is like boston dynamics i
think does that a lot um all right chaos
eight eight uh a tournament tim do some
research on cardano crater is
anti-establishment one of cardinals
projects is to turn africa into a
blockchain powerhouse win-win imo i have
four cryptos i've got bitcoin ethereum
doge and uh cardano
and it's because i think uh i've
cardano's similar to ethereum and i'm
confident in it personally i'm not
giving you advice i'm just telling you
what i think and we have an open
invitation for the founder of cardano to
come on the show and talk crypto with us
so uh you know there's that
all right
eric miller says the chicken shortage
could be a result of a cyber attack on
pilgrim's pride a chicken processing
plant
interesting but the chicken shortage has
been around for a month or two because
i've been covering it for a minute
gb daniello says glad to see you cover
this i also cover these topics please
check out my channel i'd be glad to move
and help out with your media company i
make films and music too entertainment
all my life
you know we've got
there's there's uh
we want to move as fast as possible in
expanding the company but there's like
regulation
stands in the way it makes it very
difficult plus there's good business
practices you know it's not all not all
government but we try
all right i'm brandon says i'm a chicken
hauler and i can vouch that the chicken
shortage is true my company dropped a
hatchery because the breeders can't keep
up with demand
wow why are the chickens not having
babies
what is that i don't know not of chicken
food i don't know
chickens just eat grass and butter
all right john marafa says interesting
how the left tells us stop using gas or
eating meat and now those two industries
are targeted by hackers hmm what's next
yeah i don't know
reuben
pedroza says guys this is not shortage
in beef chicken produce or even gas the
hacks are in the payment systems the
companies would rather shut shut the
world down if they don't get paid reuben
you are incorrect there is actually a
shortage of chicken and beef outside of
the cyber attacks over the past several
months several restaurants have been
reporting that they've been struggling
to get chicken supplies and oil because
it's not there because people aren't
working and people aren't making things
so things aren't there to buy there was
however two major cyber attacks colonial
pipeline and this jbs system which is
not chicken and that resulted in them
shutting down because it was going to
affect their computer systems that's
separate from the already existent meat
shortages that happened before the cyber
attacks
deadbeat gamers says snow piercer was a
book
film about two sides the last humans
rich and poor surviving ice age two on a
train spoiler warning the rich eat only
good food and the poor eat cricket
protein bars i remember this is uh i
don't know about the book but i can tell
you in the film it's roaches
and i can also tell you in the original
take of the film there's a scene where
chris evans
he opens this vat
that's making these these brown bars
they eat and you see a bunch of roaches
and he's like oh he gets really sick
because in the movie they were eating
roaches the original cut it was human
excrement gross oh brutal and i guess
test audiences really did
because the only food they had was like
these bars and i'm kind of like where do
the roaches come from what do the
roaches eat
the human waste
made more sense i don't know how you eat
it or process that but
i don't think i have a problem with
eating roaches if there was no food left
i'd just be like i will eat what i got
to eat and i will i will be happy about
it you know you know what it is when
you're starving
everything tastes good that's for sure
it's true it's true man
it's part of the great thing about
having a really clean diet is when you
eat a carrot it's super sweet carrots
are ridiculously sugary oh sweet yeah
you you get a good carrot chop it up
steam it i'll tell you you and i tweeted
we've we've done so much trying to make
our food taste better and better and
better to the point of like heavily
processing it
dropping every known spice imaginable
plus a cup of brown sugar right on top
of that piece of chicken
preservatives
you know i had for breakfast today i had
two eggs straight from a chicken's butt
oh walked right into chicken coop picked
them up cleaned them off cracked them
open over easy man that is delicious
they taste noticeably different i don't
know they're just delicious color for
sure it's just delicious
i like i like having the yolk just a
little bit just over easy and then you
cut off the whites and you just eat the
yolk or you cut off the the whites i eat
them but i'm talking about interesting i
like eating the yolks by themselves
it is so delicious
so you you want to eat real food man
we we got these really nice steaks that
fat from the steaks it is delicious you
don't need anything
you don't need this double triple cheese
with fancy sauce chipotle splash
every known processed garbage schlopped
into a deep fried you don't need any of
that no and it's a lot of times those
are salt overload if like restaurant
food is just salt
all you need to do is go outside take a
nice cicada off
don't eat this kids
media is telling you damn don't eat them
getting people are posting people are
posting carrots in the chat now you look
at you yes get juicy where i grew up um
my whole life my closest neighbor middle
of nowhere pa we would always get the
eggs from it was a dollar they were
fresh eggs so i ate that my entire life
i went to college i didn't know it was
actually eggs like i felt stupid because
of the color i was like no no no the
eggs like actual eggs are so much more
yellow and then two farms down that's
where i got we got our meat my entire
life they're blue eggs oh just like the
shell is blue yeah of
there are like in existence yeah and
there's green ones oh just like a cross
yeah i mean don't like some robin stuff
have blue eggs and that's so yeah the
chickens we have the guy we bought them
from called it a sampler it's like it's
a bunch of different kind of chickens
and so some like blue eggs some white
some brown there's like greenish blue
were you saying that chicken yolk is
more yellow yeah the actual like egg
when you cook it is like way more
vibrantly yellow
like a fresh did you know that the beef
you eat in the store is cloned beef what
yeah i didn't i didn't believe that we
had alex jones on the show and he was
like you know people don't realize
they're eating cloned and beef yeah and
i'm like alex that's not true you're
making this and he was like look it up
i'm not i was like all right i looked it
up and it was like you are eating corned
beef and i was like whoa i didn't know
that
that's crazy dude
yeah we're eating cloned meat they clone
the meat
that's weird and then they just grow
like the meat patty no they like they
like clone it and just inseminate the
cow i guess wow that's easier than just
bringing a bowl in or something oh
you know it's like the same thing with
apples they used to be like a whole
bunch of different kinds of apples now
there's like four same with bananas yeah
there should be a bunch of different
kinds
yeah soon we're gonna have just one
vegetable it's gonna be called like food
[Laughter]
and it's gonna be like a weird starchy
semi-sweet red thing in a cube shape
that grows perfectly mmm gross yeah i
mean it's gonna be like the consistency
of meat it'll be like if you eat it
backwards it's salty but if you eat it
forward it's sweet
i don't know if i'm like really
connecting weird dots here but a lot of
people in the community it's it's a
fickle uh opinion on jim cramer
sometimes he loves ames and tells the
shorts to get out other times they hate
him
um but just last week people were
talking he's like yeah amc is finding
everything but the next thing to run is
beyond me
and now with this conversation i'm like
thinking even more about it he was like
really pushing beyond me he's not wrong
i don't know i don't know if it's beyond
me though but he's on the right track so
they're doing cell culture meats
look man we've had these reports come
out saying you can't eat beef because
it's bad for the environment
and you've got big pushes against
climate change it is
legit bad for the environment for to eat
beef because like you've got to grow
grow the vegetables like well you get i
think what a cows eat alfalfa yes hay
and grass
but it takes a lot of water to produce a
full-grown cow and then to harvest the
cause a lot of labor and
as the media's already said you could
just eat the cicadas right
so what they're doing is they're trying
to find meat alternatives that people
would enjoy so they're doing beyond
burgers
impossible burgers
i definitely think those are going to be
a huge run the problem is they're
extremely salty
uh have you ever had impossible or
beyond meat they're good yeah uh i i i
actually i had a um i think beyond is
way better than impossible it's my
opinion yeah me too they both have a ton
of salt too much salt i would have no
problem with them not having salt in
them yeah salmon why do they know
because i guess they got to make it
taste good the cell cultured stuff i
find weird
but i also if it's food it's food i
guess whatever
i don't know if i've had the cell
culture but i've had those i don't know
if they sell those widespread yet the
cell culture burgers
it's actual beef but it's like grown in
a lab into the shape of a burger and
with that it's less uh the impact on the
environment's less still oh
substantially substantially less yeah so
i definitely think when you look at
these meat shortages
what's going to happen is you remove
enough meat from the market you drive
the price up enough people will start
buying other things
they'll be like i guess i can't buy beef
so what are they what do they buy
they'll buy whatever they can get
they'll start buying other things to
replace it if they have no choice if you
come out and you're like we are passing
a law that says beef is no longer legal
people would throw pitchforks they'd
they'd be running around with pitchforks
like javelins
and and torches and all that stuff but
if you're just like it's a cyber attack
you know there's like we don't have any
now people go man that's crazy right
they'll just eat something else yeah you
can't you won't be able to legislate
this change to the great reset it's
going to have to be a necessity so
whether it's intentional or not this is
the first path towards removing burgers
from our diet dude i'm so pumped about
stem cell meat i'm so pumped you'll be
able to order like a packet of powder
and then you put it in your machine and
then whatever else enzymes or whatever
and then after like six days
you have like meat patties or whatever
you have like five pounds of ground chug
yeah but there's no fat in it excellent
you have to add like fat to it or
something wild yes i don't know if it
works though it's not the same i don't
know no brain involved no heartbeat it's
just a piece of me will vegans eat it i
will i would yeah because it doesn't
harm the animal if i was vegan i would
eat it because it's not an animal it
isn't i'm not a thing and i do eat meat
if i was i would eat it but it's not an
animal you know it's like an animal
product it is an animal product i guess
you could say that all right let's read
some more super chats we got ben walker
he says tim you're significantly more
tech literate than the average bear but
many viewers may not be in light of this
second attack would you consider having
a cyber security expert on who could
help explain different threat actors and
their motives absolutely and i know a
whole bunch so i'll just have to reach
out to some of them
all right
alex 9513 says moon gang shout out to
chair you've been making the rounds matt
ape together strong and then it's an ape
a duck and a strong arm
there you go
ducks
c griff 142 says if a civil war would
happen the left end cities don't realize
how isolated they would be we could cut
off food and fuel supplies pretty easily
that is correct
all right
holly wiley says tim i told you about
tje meat earlier it's much worse read my
tweets to you
holly j wiley all right let me uh let me
let me pull this up and see what the
what's going on something else i don't
know what tje meets is
so we'll see what uh what is what are
you tweeting about holly you tweeting
about something thank you holly thanks
for getting in touch with us about that
super chat what is tje meat
i see an ad for dogecoin oh is it
possible that it was t-h-e-meet the meat
oh is that what it is maybe it's j next
to h oh it is so it's the meat okay
about the meat earlier oh okay so you're
saying it's worse i don't see your tweet
about the meat we'll have to come back
to it but uh meat tweet
liberty or death says gme and roaring
kitty changed the world by accident i
had never traded stocks until january
because of people like matt i spent the
last five months learning no going back
now you know it
the throne says hey guys just wondering
what you guys think about the hedera
hashgraph or about the central bank
digital currency there's a year-long
research project currently being
performed in the u.s for this
i haven't heard of the hashgraph of you
fed coin
definitely it's coming you see bc
central bank coin cbc or something
that's that's inevitable i'm surprised
that they're so far behind but i'm
actually not surprised i'm not surprised
noticing
big robb says short interest is
self-reported it is likely much higher
as the as the fine for being caught
lying is just the cost of doing business
another crucial factor is utilization
which amc has been at 99.5 to 100 for
six weeks now yeah what does that mean
so utilization is the it's a ratio of
just the amount of shares on loan
divided by the total amount that could
theoretically be borrowed at that moment
in time so it's like almost maxed out
it's maxed out but both are dynamic
because it's the amount of people who
want to loan them out so if someone like
blackrock's like i do want to loan mine
out sure i'll take the interest payments
they'll do it but then they could also
take that supply away so really you have
to know
the short interest the shares on loan
and the utilization to get the like the
full picture you need all three because
they describe a different part of like
the mathematical equation
clayton andrews says i'm a cattle
rancher from canada thanks for reporting
on the cyber attack planning on selling
lightweight steers this week but are
going to look at markets to see if we
should hold uh we should hold annoys me
how ag is society surf class that us no
society that's true yeah
michael moyer says i agree we need to
stop using woke descriptions and call a
spade a spade blm no go zones that's
what that's that's what they are my dad
and i made a docu-series explaining what
they represent please watch
christianaction.org super chat need help
to get it out free for everyone and
there you go
rylo 704 says you guys are familiar with
the green new deal and you're honestly
thinking that oil and beef were attacked
with no reprisal from the feds not to
sound like a q-nut but do you believe
it's coincidence
maybe
it was crazy that's simple i mean crazy
to think that the u.s government would
attack its own infrastructure to get
some sort of political movement
i know so they have done that but they
didn't know gulf of tonka was just
claimed they were attacked
they claimed they were attacked when
they were right there was no actual
there is operation northwoods northwoods
wanted to get us into uh
cuba isn't that what that was wanted to
stage false flag attacks i heard that
the that what's his name fdr knew that
we were going to be attacked by japan
leading up but they didn't know where or
when so they were just kind of like ah
we need an excuse to get into the war so
here it comes
yeah i i you know i'm it would be great
to actually talk to a historian who can
go into the nitty gritty details on that
stuff but uh there i've i've definitely
heard that you know fdr was like well if
it happens it happens like then we'll
get in the war i guess and so pearl
harbor yeah so but it's it's a question
of
i'm not an expert on that stuff yeah it
seems so circuitous to attack our own
infrastructure like this just to get a
new deal passed that doesn't make sense
to me but then i know it's a global
thing this world is not an american
system i'm not a fan of conspiracies
because they make too many assumptions
like the reality is we were doing
weapons deals with with uh
like with countries that japan was
enemies with and so they got mad at us
and then they were like yo stop doing it
and plus we had a base in hawaii which
is the middle pacific and they're like
dude you're encroaching and they're like
we're gonna we're gonna you know push
you back and then we were like guess
what we actually got a nuclear bomb and
they didn't know about that
so they thought u.s is putting pressure
on us we're not going to tolerate it
we're going to go fight and then the us
was like yeah you know here's a here's a
gravity bomb for you hold my beer
yeah don't mess around
all right let's see where we got some
soup jets christian kristen lloyd says
you just lost the game oh gosh that was
a that was a that was a mean thing to do
you know you meet me
heather v says my town provides 25 of
nations beef cows are sold at bottom
dollar so there's no reason beef is so
expensive the pens are stuffed full and
they've been going the whole time
there's no shortage weird i mean in your
town but there's literally shortages
reported across the board and i went
like a mile from my house and the
barbecue joint has a big sign saying we
can't sell beef it's too expensive
something's wrong somewhere yup
someone's doing something
something
is not if something is is not right
something is quite wrong
i can feel it tanner larson says keep
the good work guys what is the end game
with bitcoin what happens with the debt
held by japan china and the public who
mow the majority of our country's bonds
if bitcoin becomes a standard the dollar
implodes and those holding bitcoin
become wealthy
the end game with bitcoin is that it
will be worth around the equivalent of a
million or so dollars and it'll
stabilize between half a million in a
million at some point it won't stabilize
completely but it'll stay pretty steady
and then you'll have bitcoin which will
affect effectively function like your
bank account
when you want to store money you
transfer it into bitcoin and you just
leave it and there's a public ledger
like a bank and then when you want to
spend cash you'll switch to doge or
something or litecoin or bitcoin cash
whatever is easier people will probably
accept crypto they'll probably say
crypto they'll be like we take crypto
and then you'll be like it doesn't
matter what your token is there have
been a bunch of attempts at creating
rapid transaction yeah so that if
someone says we it's 10 bitcoin you can
select doge and then just hit it and
then it'll do the equivalent of doge to
bitcoin if you have it
a bunch of systems trying to do
something like that
alright
terry diffy says great job great show
why don't you and shows like yours
crowder shapiro ruben joined forces to
create a super group couldn't be ignored
then everybody's running their own thing
i guess
cam s says neil tyson on jre depicts the
great reset and an hour 32 and 20
seconds
leads into an example of owning a drill
and not using it so we'll have to rent
and have shared commodity that's correct
you'll need a specific tool and you'll
have a subscription service
i saw a commercial today for kitty poo
club
and i was like we've jumped the shark
first there's like there you know
there's there's like clubs like dollar
shave club and it's like when i first
saw that i was like do you really need a
brand new razor once a month
i guess it's easy just shows up at your
doorstep so you get your razor you get
your replacement razors and everything
i'm like okay wasteful then i saw one i
see a bunch of these clubs that like
kind of don't make sense and then i saw
a kitty poo club
and i'm like all right we've done it
you know that one actually makes sense
what is it it's a cardboard box
and it comes with just just enough
litter to where you put it up and you
fill it up and then at the end of the
like a week or whatever a new one
arrives you just toss it it's just
cardboard so you don't get wasteful
plastics for like your plastic boxes and
you don't got to worry about digging
through cat poop you just throw in the
trash and then you pop up in the new box
it's amazing it kind of is yeah i used
to like
be kind of i'm i'm from the 90s you know
so i was from from the 80s
from the 70s yeah from the 70s
i was obsessed with owning my own music
so i wanted like a burn em on cds i had
it all on my hard drive and then spotify
and all these like streaming networks
came out and i hated the idea that i
didn't own it that i was it's like this
great reset thing they want you to not
own it but and i hated it i wanted it
because i want to know the same with
video games i don't like that all my
games are on steam i would like to have
a hard copy but now
having this amazon computer be able to
be like play this song play this song
play this song i don't it's amazing
so maybe there is something to it we
don't own movies anymore yeah you don't
own your movie on amazon you bought it
you bought the you don't own the
software on your phone you bought the
right to view it yeah
the license to it
all right clubfoot billy says just here
to throw out some love for matt and much
love for you too tim keep on keeping on
and keep those good vibes going will do
nova zero says hashgraph is a consensus
mechanism it's kind of pointless because
it requires that each party on it is
authenticated to even participate which
defeats the point attractive to
centralized institutions interesting
all right let's see sidekick says tim
you keep saying unemployment is causing
a work shortage in jobs typically held
by teenagers they don't get unemployment
maybe they're just lazy
they're not typically held by teenagers
maybe they were 20 30 years ago yeah
that's not the case anymore
jensen zeiger says west virginia is
doing a gun lottery for the vaccine also
we don't have a wawa in texas but we do
have qt and buckies
what's the other one there's another one
that's kind of like huawei i can't
remember the name of it
man i can't remember the name oh well
whatever yeah west virginia is doing a
gun lottery guns and trucks right i
don't know how to feel about that how
does it work so your guns and trucks
awarded it potentially as a lottery if
you get a vaccine yep
you know what i find creepy about is i'm
like you gotta talk to your doctor about
like your medical history because
there's a story right now about a band a
punk rock band i shouldn't call him punk
rock i should call them like
establishment rock yeah establishment
rock called teenage bottle rocket
they're super pro establishment they
love government they love big massive
multinational corporations
super big fans of big pharmaceuticals
and all that stuff just they love the
system anyway they're doing a show where
it's a thousand dollars to watch them
play
but if you're vaccinated you get a
discount it's only eighteen dollars
well some woman complained because she
went to our doctor and her doctor said
you've had covet two recently you can't
get the vaccine so now she's not allowed
to go to the show because she can't
afford it
that's screwed up so these guys are like
if you're rich you don't have to get a
vaccine and it's like that's that's a
terrible message it should you should
not do that
well there you go
that's why i don't like the idea of like
of lottery it's like no no you go to
your doctor and here's here's what i
tell people talk to your doctor ask them
about your medical history you want to
be careful because like you go to the
cdc website it'll tell you list of
ingredients it tells you what allergies
to be aware of and you ask your doctor
about it it's that simple don't take
political opinions from people your
doctors have political opinions too but
you want to make sure you're getting
sound medical advice
you know all that stuff hard to come by
yeah
all right bill h says corn prices are
way up corn is feed to livestock corn
ethanol is used for gas it's a domino
effect that makes sense that's right
we've subsidized corn it is going to
keep happening all right let's do a
couple more here
jay smith says what is project dragonfly
what is it being used for who funded the
project and who is asking for this very
very relevant interesting oh look it up
eric moe says coors you're needed at the
office bright and early tomorrow i don't
want to hear you're tired from taking
glamour shots all night and then four
duck emojis
[Laughter]
all right
last we'll do one we'll do one more
number one underscore to you says have
you heard about china threatening
nuclear war over probes into the origin
of c19 i did not but that is creepy
wow i certainly hope that's not the case
all right my friends there's gonna be a
bonus segment up at timcast.com at about
11 but make sure you smash that like
button right now just help us out give
smash and share the show with your
friends you can follow the show on
facebook at tim cast irl share the clips
from the show to help get more people to
pay attention and follow us on instagram
at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast we do the show
monday to friday at 8pm even on holidays
like yesterday so we will back tomorrow
uh matt you want to shout out your
socials and your channel and all that
yeah if you want to kind of follow along
what's going on stocks options crypto um
twitter matt underscore course instagram
twitch all that same thing matt
underscore course and then on youtube
just matt korres keep it simple nice you
can follow me in crossland.net and uh at
ian crossland along all lines of social
media and check out my music on amazon
and spotify while you're at it
very cool and you guys i really want at
least 10 000 likes on this episode we
had like 35 000 people tuned in to watch
which is really awesome matt was super
popular i feel like we should have at
least 10 000 likes right right okay
there we go all right anyway you guys
can follow me at on twitter at sour
patch list and help me beat sour patch
kids and follower count there's
something you could do now you can ask
your little robot device maybe it's from
amazon or google to play will of the
people by tim cast and it will actually
play that song and for those that aren't
familiar just search for it on youtube
and check out the music video it's a
short film we released it back in
november it's uh critical of everyone in
politics maybe you'll like it if you
like rock music we got i'm working on
more so we'll see how things uh turn out
in the future but uh i'm really excited
because we just finally got it listed on
spotify and itunes and everything so you
can now you know get it so thanks for
hanging out go to timcast.com become a
member the bonus segment will be up some
point around 11 usually when it goes up
and we'll see you all there bye guys
you